So
Und bisschen früher aber es ist ja glaube ich also gestern wäre es glaube ich ja schon 39 gewesen ich kann mir das immer nicht merken
was genau vor und was zurückstellen heißt und ich kann mir nicht mal merken wann wie vor und
zurück und was auch immer gestellt wird
Ist auch scheißegal weil nach spätestens zwei drei tagen ist man eh komplett dran gewöhnt am besten ist man ignoriert das einfach und guckt einfach auf die Uhr
Gab es da nicht
Gab es da nicht vor vier oder fünf jahren oder noch vielleicht noch länger her weiß nicht gab es da nicht irgend so eine abstimmung
ob die zeitumstellung
abgeschafft werden soll und da haben irgendwie 80 prozent oder so zumindest zumindest die mehrheit weiß ich mal wie viel es wirklich waren
gesagt kein bock mehr auf zeitumstellung
Aber da hat sich nichts getan oder?
Also kam nie was raus bei
Es war auch ein bisschen sinnbildlich für zu viel bürokratische scheiße die wir am start haben
9 leute
Eine milliarde bits huge
Jetzt kommen sie alle ja
Richtig
Quasi der der poggers im koggers
ja chat
Gucken zeige ich das jetzt auch mal
Wow
Nitta hat keine sich keine keine verbindung weiß ich was sie machen ob let's encrypt
Da nicht mitmacht zumindest was ich euch zeigen wollte ist folgendes guckt mal hier
Extremly
gestern neue bestzeit gerannt
Und hier da
Alter kann man das bild nicht einfach
Doch hier bild kann man auch mal kommen hier gestern neue bestzeit geflitzt
Fünf kilometer
Knapp 28 minuten ist aber auch echt also das letzte das letzte war irgendwie
Ich hatte ich habe es ich habe es auf twitter reingeschrieben hier kommt mal das letzte war
Genau meine letzte bestzeit war 8 51 und jetzt 8
28 minuten 6
Ich habe keine ahnung seriously wie manche leute
Das sind unter 20 minuten rennen
Absolut kein plan wie das funktionieren soll man
Ich bin komplett
Decke haben wir haben wir wenn warum habe ich decken ihr wisst was ich
Warum habe ich decken nicht als als emot aller das ding mit dem sark moment ich muss ich muss kurz decken hinzufügen
Kann man das nicht usen doch doch habe ich doch decken
Als ich bin komplett decken wenn ich das gerannt bin ich habe echt keine ahnung wie das manche leute schaffen unter 20 minuten zu rennen
Und wisst ihr was so viel krasser ist
Der marathon weltrekord der läuft nicht das hier für 42 kilometer
der läuft doppelt so schnell
für 42 kilometer
Ziemlich ziemlich genau ziemlich genau doppelt so schnell
Der läuft irgendwie
2250 oder so pro pro kilometer das ist komplett ich habe keine ahnung wie das überhaupt möglich sein soll ja
Naja gut ich meine es ist halt der unterschied zwischen leute die das
die gewisses talent dafür haben das irgendwie schon seit 100 jahren gefühlt machen und
Auch ihr ganze ganze der typische also der marathon weltrekord halter wobei das stimmt nicht es gab letztens
Es gab letztens es gab letztens neuen weltrekord aber sagen wir mal der der ehemalige weltrekord halter der ist ziemlich genauso alt wie ich
Der ist auch 1984 geboren
Der ich sage der langjährige marathon weltrekord halter ist auch 1984 geboren ist genauso alt wie ich
Oder fast genauso alt wie ich ich glaube da ist sogar ich glaube der ist sogar einen monat älter als ich
Und
Der rennt das einfach mit
2 minuten 50 pro kilometer über 42 kilometer ich habe keine ahnung wie das geht
Das ist komplett unverständlich für mich als die richtig krasse dudes
Der macht das schon und er kommt aus kenia wo die wohl richtig krasse auch
Nachwuchsförderung und sowas für wird ich glaube das ist wahrscheinlich die einzige sportart wo sie das haben aber
Ja ja
Aber da gibt es da geht richtig ab
Ne nicht kenia doch kenia kenia ich glaube kenia da wo die ganzen runner leute herkommen
Ja ich bin 1984 geboren
1984 geboren in offenbach
Nicht frankfurt offenbach
Offenbach und zwar
Ich weiß nicht wie das krankenhaus heißt
Dass das in der richtung vom hauptbahnhof vom offenbacher hauptbahnhof in dem krankenhaus bin ich geboren
Ich habe aber ich war aber nie in offenbach länger lange längere zeit ich war mal in der schule in offenbach ganz kurz so zwischendurch mal
Aber ich bin also ich habe mit offenbach nix am nix am hut gehabt bisher
Früher hat man ja gesagt offenbach ist noch mehr asi als gerade also vor allem wegen dem hohen ausländeranteil
Offenbach ist noch mehr asi als frankfurt mittlerweile bin ich mir nicht so sicher ob ich das noch unterschreiben würde
Ein frankfurt hat auch irgendwie schon ganz schön abgebaut wobei das stimmt nicht eigentlich hat eigentlich hat frankfurt nicht abgebaut gerade im hauptbahnhof
Es ist im vergleich zu den 90er und anfang 2000er jahren viel angenehmer
Also es gibt ja immer noch am frankfurt am hauptbahnhof massig
Obdachlose wobei das gar nicht mal so das ding ist sondern die ganzen drogensüchtigen
Aber nicht mehr so krass wie früher die haben sie ein bisschen vertrieben in die die umliegenden straßen
Stimmt also meine gamin uhr ist der meinung mein fitness age ist glaube ich ist glaube ich 40
So ja
Aber wer weiß was das was das zeug da anzeigt
Also ich behaupte einfach mal dass wenn ich mir die dudes die leute die mir da so täglich
Wenn ich war also täglich bin ich ja nicht in frankfurt gute frage ja sage ich gleich was zu
So über den weg laufen also gamin ist ja der meinung ich bin moment ich muss euch das mal vorlesen ich bin ich bin unter
Jetzt 30 prozent vom fitness level
Für mein age entsprechend ganz ehrlich wenn ich in frankfurt so rumlaufen mir die leute angucke kann ich mir nicht vorstellen dass 50
Prozent der leute fitter sind ich bin nicht wirklich fit aber was darum läuft
Die kommen teilweise also da kommt ein großteil der leute schafft es ja kaum von der u-bahn irgendwie
Hoch zum willi brandplatz ohne dass sie komplett verausgabt sind also ich habe da habe ich so meine zweifel
Ob das vielleicht vielleicht 50 prozent von dem was war gamin angemeldet ist und die leute da angemeldet sind die bewegen sich vielleicht auch ein bisschen
Keine ahnung
Wie oft ich aktuell im office bin so im durchschnitt einmal die woche ja gehe ich auch mal von aus wahrscheinlich wahrscheinlich
Also ich bin einmal die woche aktuell in frankfurt ungefähr so im durchschnitt ich war auch schon zweimal ich war auch schon gar kein mal
Aber so im durchschnitt ungefähr einmal die woche und ich finde dass das eigentlich ganz guter
Ganz guter rhythmus es ist jedes mal immer übelst ineffektiv und abfuck nach frankfurt zu fahren
Also auf der einen seite man fährt halt mit wenn du mit der bahn fährst ist wenn da muss ich mich jetzt nicht da muss ich
mich jetzt nicht
Großartig darüber auslassen ihr wisst ihr wisst was sache ist
aber
Es ist auch arbeitstechnisch extrem ineffektiv
Also wenn ich in frankfurt bin wenn ich das mal vergleiche was ich in frankfurt geschafft kriege ist das fast nix
Versus im daheim eigentlich normal
Mir ist es übrigens ein rätsel wie ich das früher geschafft habe ich verstehe es wirklich ich kann es nicht mehr nachvollziehen es gibt
So ein paar sachen die die verstehe ich überhaupt nicht also
Das erste ist wie ich überhaupt früher wie wir überhaupt als wir damals alle noch ins büro mussten
Jetzt halt bei der alten bei dem alten arbeitgeber ist ja egal wie wir da überhaupt was auf die reihe gekriegt haben das war
ja damals schon genau so ineffektiv wie heute
aber
Irgendwie ging es und
Wahrscheinlich hat man sich daran gewöhnt dass es damals alles viel
Arschlager gewesen ist
Es gibt so ein paar sachen die verstehe ich halt nicht wie ich das geschafft habe das erste ist was ich absolut nicht verstehe ist
Wie ich es geschafft habe fünf tage die woche arbeiten zu gehen
Das gibt bestimmt einige die denken sich was will der jetzt von mir ist doch ganz normal und es ist bestimmt auch vieles gewöhnungssache dabei
Aber ich verstehe es nicht ich kann es mir nicht mehr vorstellen fünf tage die woche zu arbeiten und noch schlimmer
Ich kann es mir nicht vorstellen
Fünf tage die woche nach frankfurt zu fahren du machst ja nix
Du stehst also ich bekomme muss ich vorstellen und was ich mir auch noch mehr vorstellen kann ich bin aufgestanden teilweise um
5 uhr ich bin jahrelang muss ich mal vorstellen
jahrelang um 5 45 aufgestanden
Nach frankfurt gefahren mit der bahn teilweise mit dem bus noch zum bahn zum hauptbahnhof in hanau
Mit dem bus alter noch noch noch wohl wo ich noch in der alten wohnung gewohnt habe noch nicht noch nicht hier im opa haus
mit dem bus zum hauptbahnhof
Und dann das fünf
Fünfmal die woche nach frankfurt und die bahn war ja damals schon scheiße die war vielleicht nicht ganz so extrem scheiße wie jetzt
Anteilmäßig weil jetzt ist ja komplett du kannst ja eigentlich davon ausgehen dass es nicht passiert was auf der was was auf dem plan steht
Aber
Die war auch schon kacke fünfmal die woche nach frankfurt um fünf
Also wisst ihr ich habe das damals überhaupt nicht realisiert weil das für mich halt ganz
Komplett normal gewesen ist ich bin dann übrigens morgen morgens auch immer
Ins rechenzentrum gegangen damals da war es noch schon dunkel da konnte man so ein bisschen
Abschicken
Aber chillen sagt mir heute wahrscheinlich was sagt mir wie sagt man heute noch mal zum
Wenn man sich entspricht keiner da konnte man ins rechenzentrum noch und ich bin dann immer durch unsere
In frankfurt durch unsere rechenzentren die was da wo man easy zu fuß hingekommen ist das das erste war ja quasi schräg über die straße schon
Bin ich immer bin ich immer durch die rechenzentren gegangen relativ langsam und habe mir alles angeguckt ob alles noch okay aussieht und sowas
Da warst du noch mal über eine stunde unterwegs halt mehr oder weniger im dunklen ich habe auch nie
licht angemacht morgens im rechenzentrum
Bin da immer im dunklen durchgelaufen
Das war das das war tatsächlich noch ein bisschen
Extended extended bettgeteim
Aber gut wenn ihr 45 aufgestanden seid und nach frankfurt gefahren dann bin ich direkt rüber
rucksack rüber hingestellt sonst wie
rüber gegangen
Da bin ich dann eineinhalb stunden oder so bin ich rechenzentrum rund gelaufen das war ein bisschen extended extended bettgeteim aber trotzdem
Ich verstehe es nicht bus und bahn fünf tage die woche und wisst ihr was ich mich da am meisten frage ist
Warum also wie habe ich überhaupt noch zusätzlich sachen auf die reihe gekriegt
Ich meine ich arbeite jetzt vier tage
Und mach hauptsächlich homeoffice und ich habe jetzt schon den eindruck
Irgendwie ich krieg nix auf die reihe mehr so
Und also so drumherum großartig ja und damals bin ich fünf tage die woche nach frankfurt gefahren
Nicht vier tage fünf tage und habe es irgendwie geschafft mit dem fabian
Stundenlang kurz zu grinden
Und und und und anzufangen youtube videos zu machen
Ich weiß noch ich bin teilweise heimgekommen mittags also was das mittags bin ich da bin ich dann also zurückgefahren 16 uhr
16 26 oder so bin ich glaube ich gefahren mit dem zug
Ich habe ich bin dann heimgekommen
Habt die xbox angemacht hab drei vier runden gespielt hatte irgendein gameplay etwas drüber gelabert habs hochgeladen dann war es irgendwie
1830 19 uhr oder so
Damals noch 720 p 30 fps scheiß bitrate weil nur dsl 3000 zum applaud ich habe keine ahnung wie ich das alles auf die reihe gekriegt
habe
Komplett komplett unverständlich keine ahnung wie das funktioniert hat
Ja ja naja ne mit dem fahrrad ins office fahren ist tatsächlich nicht so nicht so gut man schwitzt ja da schon so ein bisschen
Ich werde zurückfahren mit dem fahrrad oder auch im winter also wenn ich wenn ich denn wieder ein fahrrad habe
Weil ihr wisst ja meins ist ja ein bisschen in mitleidenschaft gezogen obwohl das erste knapp über einen monat alt ist
Ich werde das fahrrad einfach morgens im
Zug mitnehmen
Und mittags mittags heimfahren ich bin die strecke schon mal gefahren
Also sind ungefähr wenn man den angenehmen weg fährt also immer nur am main lang der ist zwar ein bisschen länger
Als als halb durch offenbach durch aber insgesamt deutlich angenehmer
Das ist ja mein wie heißt das ding ich glaube ich glaube einfach einfach meinen mein radweg da geht er irgendwie von mainz bis
Anna schaffen durch vorbei bis bis irgendwie sonst wo halt ganz ganze strecke am main
Und das sind 27 kilometer hin und 27 kilometer zurück umgefähr
das bin ich auch letztens
Wartet mal das bin ich auch letztens gefahren hin und zurück aber an einem stück also irgendwie 74
54 kilometer und das ging tatsächlich ganz gut ja hier
guckt hier sieht man es
Hier bin ich nach frankfurt gefahren
ja
da ging mein fahrrad noch
Hier bin ich nach frankfurt gefahren und
Es hat gedauert insgesamt zweieinhalb stunden
Zweieinhalb stunden aber du konntest auch teilweise überhaupt nicht richtig fahren weil gerade so die letztes letzte drittel ist halt extrem viel los in frankfurt
Auch wenn du durchfährst runter runter an meinen aber es geht es geht tatsächlich ganz gut
Ja das war tatsächlich auch das längste was ich gefahren bin
Also wir haben in frankfurt gibt es es gibt ein paar fahrgang paar ganz gute fahrradwege
So straßen in frankfurt leider nix von hanau nach frankfurt es gibt seit jahren
planung moment hanau frankfurt
frankfurt fahrrad schnell schnell weg
Du findest ein prinzip nur noch so meldung das ist das ist das ist wieder ohne scheiß ein
unglaublicher bürokratische aktion scheiß fahrradweg zu bauen man da könnte ich mich wieder also wenn ich davon habe könnte ich mich da
Richtig drüber aufregen weil man darf nicht vergessen
in der zeit
Wo die brauern sie wollen nur mal kurz kurz zusammenfassung ist die wollen 22
Relativ gerade durchgehende fahrradwege bauen von hanau nach frankfurt einmal südlich von meinen einmal nördlich von meinen
Oder westlich von meiner keine ahnung also einmal einmal auf meiner seite und einmal auf der anderen seite von meinen so viel ja
so
Und so und
Und jetzt ist das ding jetzt ist das ding beide beide dieser dieser wege kommen nicht voran
Und lokal wird das hier immer verkauft als super krassen fortschritt das letzte was ich von diesem radweg gehört habe ist
Dass jetzt eine machbarkeit eine neue machbarkeit studie angefertigt wurde
Und wenn du so einen scheiß hörst da weißt du schon okay
Das wird nix
Ich glaube das ist der fahrradweg 5 oder so hier hier hier er genau 8
Hier genau also
7 und 8 ist das nördlich von meinen und südlich von meinen
Und das coole ist also aktuell aktuell musste halt so fahren im endeffekt
Wenn du nach frankfurt willst so das hier ist halt ihr seht halt die spaß die halt diese die hier ist ja schon der meinradweg
Du sparst dir halt diesen schlenker das sind insgesamt wahrscheinlich mal gut und gern so acht neun kilometer oder so
Die die da insgesamt spaß also sind sagen wir mal so es sind anstatt 27 sind es halt noch 20
Und der hier oben je nachdem wie man wie man da ist sogar noch ein bisschen schneller
Je nachdem wo man hin muss in frankfurt ich würde wahrscheinlich trotzdem den hier unten fahren weil ich muss willi brandplatz und so
So und die kriegen es einfach nicht geschissen
Guck hier guck hier im februar
im februar
eine absichtserklärung
unterschrieben
Um eine machbarkeit studie zu erstellen diese studie studie wurde am 20 september
2019 veröffentlicht
Anschließend übernimmt der regionale verband die das vorhaben umzusetzen jedoch stieß die erweiterfahrt teilweise auf vorbehalt deswegen
hierzu wird im spätsommer
2023 eine weitere machbarkeitsstudie vergeben alter
Das ist so bürokratie bullshit alles
Das ist so eine krasse dämliche bürokratie scheiße man da kann ich mich drüber aufregen
Oh man das ist so schlecht alter man darf sich vergessen man darf sich vergessen in china
Ja haben wir ein komplett neues viertel inklusive
inklusive häuser gebaut in zwei jahren gut ich meine wer weiß wie viele häuser wir in zwei jahren in zwei jahren
Wer weiß wie viele arbeiter in irgendeinem fundament ein betoniert sind weil sie zufällig reingefallen sind und dann kriegt die familie den brief dass er irgendwie
Heldenhaft dem dem vaterland gedient hat oder sowas keine ahnung wie das in china abgeht aber wie wäre es denn wie wäre es denn mit
einem zwischen wie wäre es dann so ein zwischending wie wäre es denn so ein zwischending ja also quasi nicht in einem jahr fertig
dafür zehn arbeiter verschüttet und wie und und vielleicht auch nicht zehn jahre für jeden scheiß brauchen
In ganz guter qualität und ohne dass leute dabei sterben das müsste doch möglich sein oder
Aber nein das ist nicht möglich
Seligen stadt frankfurter flughafen gibt es den schon ach ne ne moment ach leute ich vergaß
2020 wurde eine machbarkeitsstudie durchgeführt natürlich was sonst
und
Überhaupt schon irgendwas gebaut außer machbarkeitsstudien
Okay, okay die machbarkeitsstudie wurde 2023 oft auf basis dieser dieser studie
Bereiten die beteiligten partner kommunale okay das dauert bis fucking
2040 bis dieser weg da es man
testestly
Das dauert bis fucking 2040, bis dieser Weg da ist, man!
Das kann's doch echt nicht sein!
Guck mal, eine Online-Veranstaltung von 2012?
Die sind seit fucking zwölf Jahren...
Seit elf Jahren...
Ist das...
Kamen die auf die...
Die sind vor elf Jahren auf die Idee gekommen.
Und das krasseste, was sie bis jetzt geschafft haben, ist eine fucking Machbarkeitsstudie,
die bis Mitte des Jahres abgeschlossen wurde, man!
Das kann man sich doch nicht wirklich...
Das kann doch echt nicht sein!
Oh, ey, echt krasser Scheiß, man!
Und was macht der andere?
Ach ja, 2016 wurde eine Absichtserklärung, dann wurde wieder eine Machbarkeit.
Ich krieg Anfälle, wenn ich mir dieses bürokratische Scheiß hier in Deutschland immer angucken muss, man!
Äh...
Oh man, alter, alter!
Wahnsinn!
Wie viel der gekostet hat? Wahrscheinlich mehr, als hätten sie einfach angefangen zu bauen.
So.
Gibt's...
Gibt's ein YouTube-Video von deiner Katze?
Ja.
Ja, ja, ja.
Es gibt...
Es gibt sogar ein Video von meiner Katze, wo du alle...
Wo es alle drin zu sehen gibt.
Und zwar habe ich das während Corona gemacht, wo sich so viele Leute...
Tiere aus dem Tierheim geholt haben...
Und ich dann meine Bedenken hatte...
Seht ihr irgendwo das Video?
Wo ich dann meine Bedenken hatte...
Dass die Leute...
Die wieder abgeben...
Das ist schon so lange her...
Hier!
Hallo Leute!
Ja.
Hier!
Das ist Chico!
Das ist übrigens eine Katze, kein Kater.
Warum auch immer die Chico heißt...
Man weiß es nicht so genau.
Weil sich die ursprünglichen Besitzer gedacht haben...
Chico besser...
Keine Ahnung.
Ich weiß es nicht.
Also das ist Chico.
Das ist Chico.
Das hier ist...
Das hier ist original Katze-FPS.
Ja, die wollte immer hier hinten auf meinem Sofa...
Rumgammeln.
Boah, da hatte ich aber schon viel dickere Finger noch, oder?
Damals.
Wupp!
Wupp Pet-Emote brauchen wir jetzt.
Wir haben extra...
Wir haben extra Emotes dafür, Leute.
Wupp Pet und Wupp Pet 2.
Ja, das ist...
Die.. Und dann haben wir noch...
Das ist...
Der Name von dieser Katze ist echt das Beste.
Die...
Die wurde...
Die hieß Barbie.
Wie gesagt, ich hab die Namen nicht vergeben.
Das kommt immer aus dem...
immer aus dem...
Also...
Wo ich die...
Ich hab die Namen übernommen.
wie die halt, wie die halt vorher schon hießen und ganz ehrlich, die ist echt weit davon
entweg so die Barbie Figur zu haben, guckst du dir an ey, dicker Chonker ja und und das
hat die immer, das hat die immer extrem gerne gemacht, die hat, die hat sich immer wie ihr
hier sieht, die hat sich immer so Eichhörnchen Videos auf YouTube angeguckt, das fand die
super spannend, ihr seht es ja und manchmal, manchmal ist die sogar hier hoch und hat hinter
dem Fernseher geguckt, wo die Eichhörnchen hin sind, Willi danke für den Sub, guck die ist ganz,
die ist ganz begeistert von den Eichhörnchen im Fernseher, ja super, super spannend, das wie
gesagt auf so Zeug, das hat die ganz, konnte den ganzen Tag gucken, ich bin, ich bin teilweise mit
der ins Wohnzimmer und habe mich da hingelegt und habe Eichhörnchen mir angeguckt, weil die das
so spannend fand, auf dem Fernseher sind die Eichhörnchen so groß, wie die ganze Katze,
aber das ist egal, dafür sieht man sie gut, ja und da ist nochmal Chico, Chico im Hemd,
habt ihr, falls ihr auch Katzen habt, stehen die auch auf irgendwie voll geschwitzte Hemden,
also es fanden alle meine Katzen immer ganz besonders toll, ja, voll geschwitzte Hemden
finden die ganz toll, guckt es euch an, naja, ja, also, gibt sogar ein ganzes Video, es gibt noch
mehr, aber hier sind sie alle drei drin, hast du schon mal Oliven probiert, hä, nee, warum,
meinst du da gehen die auch total drauf ab, auf wenn das nach Oliven riecht, wie ist der Schaden,
du meinst vom Fahrrad, also wahrscheinlich komplett im Arsch, ich hatte, also es ist jetzt
ungefähr genau eine Woche her, dass ich den Unfall hatte, letzten Samstag, mit dem Fahrrad und ich
war ja in der Zwischenzeit, kann ich euch ja mal kurz erzählen, ich war in der Zwischenzeit beim
Anwalt, der hat das übernommen, ich war bei einem Gutachter, der hat irgendwie gefühlt 300 Fotos
gemacht davon und ich gehe davon aus, das Fahrrad ist total im Arsch, der hat, der Gutachter hat
auch noch Sachen gefunden, die sind mir gar nicht aufgefallen, so als Nichtkenner, ja, aber eigentlich
waren die total offensichtlich, beispielsweise, dass das Schaltwerk verbogen ist und verkratzt,
dass sogar das Sattel und das Pedal was abgekriegt hat, das zeige ich so genau, habe ich gar nicht
geguckt, ja, aber der hatte halt den Blick dafür und wisst ihr, was ich jetzt gemacht habe, ich
habe das Fahrrad daheim mal versucht auf einen, auf so einen Smart Trainer zu stellen, geht auch,
ohne Probleme, aber dadurch, dass die Schaltung schepp ist, kann ich nicht richtig schalten, was
ich mir jetzt, was ich mir jetzt gemacht habe, ich habe mir ein neues Schaltauge bestellt, ich meine,
hey, selbst wenn das Fahrrad ausgetauscht wird, 14 Euro für so einen Schaltauge, kann ich mal
ausgeben, in der Hoffnung, dass die Schaltung dann wieder halbwegs gerade ist, dass ich das Fahrrad
wenigstens die nächsten paar Monate auf dem Heimtrainer ordentlich verwenden kann. Jetzt
sehe ich scheiß Wetter, das ist nicht so schlimm, aber es ist halt echt lächerlich, du bist als derjenige,
der umgefahren wird, bist du doppelt im Arsch, du bist einmal im Arsch, weil du umgefahren wirst und
weil du Monate drauf warten musst, bis du ein neues Fahrrad kriegst, beziehungsweise dir kaufen kannst.
Ich werde es wahrscheinlich so machen, sobald irgendwie das komplett, das Gutachten komplett da
ist und wir alle davon ausgehen, so nach dem Motto, dass das quasi das Reparieren
übersteigt, denn die Kosten für ein neues Fahrrad, dann vielleicht bestelle ich mir dann schon ein neues
und warte halt, bis das Geld, das ist halt richtig scheiße. Versicherungscrap, Alter. Ja, du hast ja noch
mehr abgekriegt. Bei mir geht's, also wie gesagt, bei mir war es so, ich bin, also für alle, die es nicht
mitgekriegt haben, ich habe es letztes Mal schon erzählt, aber ich erzähle es nochmal kurz, ich bin
umgefahren worden, auf dem Fahrradweg von einem Auto, was über den Fahrradweg drüber wollte, weil, also
müsst ihr euch vorstellen, Ausfahrt, Fahrradweg, okay, nee, machen wir anders, machen wir anders, hier, Fahrradweg, okay, Fahrradweg, Ausfahrt, gestrichelt, Straße, Straße, okay, Straße, wo, wo das Auto drauf will,
aber hier, Fahrradweg, Fahrradweg, Fahrradweg, Fahrradweg, Fahrradweg, na, beste, hier, Schild, Vorfahrt achten, nee, Schwachsinn, Vorfahrt achten, Schild, und, Schild, Fahrrad, Fahrradweg, Dingsbums, von beiden Seiten, Schild,
okay, so, hier geht es ein bisschen so rum, so, und das hier, das hier bin ich, hier bin ich lang gefahren, ob Fahrradwege rot sind, oder nicht, ist doch vollkommen egal, solange da steht, dass es ein Fahrradweg ist, und solange der ein Vorfahrtschild hat, ist es vollkommen wurscht, ob das rot ist, so, so, und dann kommt hier ein Auto,
hier kommt ein Auto lang gefahren, und ist auch ein bisschen langsamer gefahren, hier, so, und fährt dann aber halt schnell weiter, und fährt mich um, so, so, an der Stelle hier, bam, bam, jetzt, hier hat sie mich umgefahren, so, und die erste Aussage, die ich von ihr gehört habe, war, oh, sie guckt hauptsächlich nach rechts, weil die kommen immer alle von rechts,
ja, das dumme ist halt nur, ich bin nicht von rechts gekommen, ich war von der anderen Seite, trotzdem ist hier alles klar geregelt, wer hier wie wo darf und wer nicht, tja, ich habe übrigens letztens in einem Video gehört, dass 60% oder so der Fahrradunfälle auf dem Fahrradweg passieren, was aber durchaus sein kann, weil das bestimmt auch Unfälle zwischen Fahrradfahrern mit einschließt,
ja, da wurde ich halt umgesäbelt, ich lag dann hier auf der Motorhaube, hier lag ich auf der Motorhaube, und bin dann runtergerutscht hier auf den Arsch, so, nachdem sie angehalten hat, das Auto hat eine richtig große Delle vorne drin in der Motorhaube, so, und ich hatte glücklicherweise nicht so viel an mir selbst,
ich hatte, ich hatte, also an der Hüfte hat es mir wehgetan, Hüfte ist noch ein bisschen, ein bisschen, wenn ich drauf drücke, merke ich noch ein bisschen, abgeschürft hier Oberschenkel und ein bisschen hier am Arm, und, ja, ein bisschen gezogen im Arm und auch am Finger, also ich merke aktuell, hattest du einen Helm auf, ja, ja, ja, hatte ich, aber ich bin glücklicherweise nicht groß auf den Kopf aufgeprallt,
ja, mir hat ein bisschen der Rücken danach wehgetan und sowas, aber, oh, passt, hast du die Polizei gerufen? Ne, ich hab Fotos gemacht, ich hab Fotos, leider hatte ich meine GoPro, ich hatte die GoPro an meinem Fahrrad dran, aber ich hatte die GoPro nicht an, weil du kannst halt mit der GoPro bloß eineinhalb Stunden aufnehmen mit dem Akku und, wollte ich, die wollte ich später dann mal anmachen, wenn ich in den ein bisschen, wenn ich in ein bisschen schöneren Ecken bin, als hier direkt an der Straße,
ja, und, bam, also wie gesagt, so 95% ist eigentlich wieder gut, Hautabschürfungen sind, sind ein bisschen noch zu sehen und ich merke sie am Daumen noch ein bisschen und vielleicht ein bisschen an der Hüfte, aber es geht, es ist, es ist, also körperlich ist fast alles wieder weg, mein Fahrrad ist halt im Arsch und ich kann jetzt nix, nix machen, weil ich warten muss, bis die Versicherung sich da irgendwie rührt
und, ich, deswegen hab ich jetzt auf meinen, hab ich auf so einen Smart Trainer geschnallt erstmal das Fahrrad, also Hinterrad raus und dann auf den Trainer drauf, Fox Subscription, ich hab Season 6 nicht mal gespielt, wie sind denn eigentlich, Leute, lohnt sich das überhaupt noch jetzt in Season 6 rein, nicht Social Plate, Steam Stats, lohnt sich das überhaupt noch?
Ey, ist gar nicht mal so, aber ist nicht auch free, ist nicht sogar free gerade irgendwie?
Mülli, danke für den Sub, heute Nudel, ja, neue Schaltung ist nicht teuer, naja, doch, ist es, also die, das, das ist eine elektronische Schaltung und da kostet, glaube ich, alleine das Schaltwerk hinten 350€ oder 250€ und das gebe ich dafür nicht mehr aus,
wenn ich mir eh neues holen muss, ja, jetzt hab ich's halt gerade, jetzt hab ich's halt gerade erzählt.
Was für einen Smart Trainer hast du? Ich hab einen Kikr, Core, die wollten besonders cool sein mit der Benahmung, das kommt so noch aus Zeiten wahrscheinlich, wo es Flikr gab und Twittr, auch Twittr hießen, nicht, noch nicht Twitter und X, ja, wieso, was ist bei dir gewesen?
Der ist voll für den Arsch, man, aha, oh, shit, Alter, okay, das ist natürlich eine Nummer härter, also bis, bis an die Scheibe bin ich, glaube ich zumindest, nicht geflogen, ich bin nur vorne auf der, auf der Motorhaube, das war ein relativ großes Auto, auf der, auf der Motorhaube gelandet, da ist jetzt richtig krasse Delle drin auf der Motorhaube, ey, richtig, die, die Motorhaube ist wirklich, die ist so, fast schon u-förmig so ein bisschen, ey.
Ja, gut, ich bin da, ich meine, du musst dir ja vorstellen, ich, ich mit meinen, sagen wir mal, noch, noch ein bisschen über 90 Kilo und dem Fahrrad da drauf, das ist schon, aber so, so heftig war es natürlich nicht, wieso, ja, das hab ich mich auch gefragt, keine Ahnung, ja, nach eigener Aussage, weil die Leute ja sonst nur von rechts kommen oder hauptsächlich von rechts kommen.
Gab's dann Stress? Ey, die war, die, die im Auto gesessen hat, die war, glaube ich, noch ein bisschen fertiger als ich, die hat so voll gezittert und so auch schon, die war komplett nervlich durch, so, aber passt, passt eigentlich, ne, die hat sich da recht kooperativ angestellt, also an der wird's nicht liegen, das Dumme ist jetzt nur, dass die Versicherung wahrscheinlich super lahm ist, hab ich letztens auch mal aus, ausprobiert, hab ich, ich hab das so gemacht, ich hab mein Fahrrad, wie gesagt, auf den, auf den, auf den Smart Trainer gepackt,
dann hab ich nen HDMI Adapter an mein, da hab ich nen HDMI Adapter an mein iPhone gepappt und hab, ich, weil, ich, das hätt ich ja dem PC irgendwie da rüber stellen müssen und so, weil ich wollt's mal im Wohnzimmer ausprobieren, HDMI Adapter ans iPhone gepackt, Zwift drauf installiert, du hast ja irgendwie 45 Minuten Trial oder sowas
Und da bin ich, da bin ich da, ich bin da 25 Kilometer gefahren in, in Zwift, war halt echt abfuck, weil die Schaltung von meinem Fahrrad nicht richtig funktioniert, ja, der skippt Gänge und gerade wenn du nach unten schaltest, skippt der halt einfach mal zwei, zwei, zwei Räder, zwei Zahnräder, was von zu leicht, zu viel, zu schwer, instant geht, also war echt schwierig zu fahren, ja, mit dem Fahrrad, aber ich, da man hat gesehen, es, es, es, es, es, es, es, es, es, es, es, es, es, es, es, es, es, es, es, es, es, es, es, es, es, es, es, es, es, es, es, es, es, es, es, es, es, es, es, es, es, es, es, es, es, es, es, es, es, es
super, super krass trainiert bin ich beim besten Willen nicht, also ich bin die 25 Kilometer gefahren auf Zwift, gut, ich weiß nicht, was das Fahrrad dazu beiträgt, ja, was kaputte Schaltung und schiefes Fahrrad, nur wer weiß, wo das alles reibt, dazu noch beiträgt, aber ich hatte im Durchschnitt, glaube ich, 1,8 Watt pro Kilo, das ist halt schlecht, aber ey, ich meine, ich mache das noch nicht lang, ja, das würde mich auch interessieren, deswegen habe ich das ja auch bei einem Anwalt übergeben, weil ich keinen Bock habe, mich damit selbst großartig auseinanderzusetzen,
echt virtuelles Schalten, das ist eine mega Idee, wie, wie schaltet man dann, mit, mit dem Handy oder wie, das ist eine gute Idee, das ist eine echt gute Idee, weil, weil dann gehe ich einfach auf irgendeinen mittleren Gang, der noch gut reingeht und, und schalte virtuell über Zwift, das ist eine echt gute Idee, was, den Zwiftcock brauche ich dann, ja, den habe ich aber nicht, ja,
F, also meins hat 3.500 Euro gekostet und ist halt auch komplett im Arsch und mal gucken, wann ich, wann ich die Kohle wieder sehe, ne, habe ich nicht, werde ich auch erstmal nicht, ich habe mir das mit dem OLED anders überlegt, irgendwas war da, warum ich es doch nicht haben wollte, ich habe die gar nicht so zusammengeschrien, ich habe, ich habe ein bisschen rumgeplärt, als ich da auf der Straße gelegen habe, so, was soll der Scheiß, hier ist fahrradfähig, keine Ahnung, irgendwas in der Richtung,
habe ich da rumgeplärt, aber die war echt fertig mit den Nerven, achso, ich dachte, es geht einfach so, was, was ist das, Zwift, Zwiftcock, okay, keine Ahnung, so, dann schauen wir uns doch mal, wie wir das jeden Sonntag machen, die Weekly Trends auf ShitHub schnell an, was da so abgeht,
Achja, ach, ich, ich wollte ja noch eines, eines zu der Zeit sagen, ne, wie gesagt, ich bin, ich bin ja hier eine neue, für mich persönlich neue Bestzeit gerannt mit knapp 28 Minuten für 5 Kilometer, aber ein bisschen gecheatet ist es, weil ich musste pausieren für, ah, 20 Sekunden oder so, weil der Bahnübergang aufgegangen ist und ich erstmal die ganzen Autos durchlassen musste,
also ich konnte so am Anfang 20 Sekunden kurz verschnaufen, bis es weiter ging, aber ich glaube, das hat jetzt nicht so krass viel ausgemacht und ich bin, ich bin auch viel zu schnell losgerannt, das habe ich gemerkt, also ich bin, ich bin losgerannt mit 5, ich habe dann auf die Uhr geguckt, irgendwann 5 Zehner Pace und da habe ich irgendwann festgestellt, alter Max, du kannst nicht mehr und da habe ich ein bisschen langsamer gemacht und das war auch eine gute Entscheidung, sonst hätte ich das nicht durchgehalten,
so, also was ist, was ist hier auf Shit beste, Leute, also hätte ich euch nichts zu dem Bild erklärt, hätte irgendjemand verstanden, was ich mit diesem Bild sagen will, ne, oder?
So, was, was trendet denn auf Shit ab? AI von Nvidia in C++, zwei Gründe, warum es mich nicht großartig interessiert, ich habe einfach genug von AI, von AI Themen in letzter Zeit und umso mehr C++, umso weniger interessiert es mich, AI, was, ich weiß nicht, was es sein soll, aber AI.
Local Airdrop, finde ich eine coole Sache, habe ich mir letztens schon angeguckt, also das Projekt, sieht, sieht eigentlich ganz nice aus, da kannst du quasi per Airdrop Dateien sharen zwischen deinem iPhone und deinem PC zum Beispiel, solange der, solange er Bluetooth hat, eigentlich eine coole Sache.
Eigentlich eine coole Sache? AI, AI, AI, nee, nicht AI. Soll, Incubator, was? Was soll das sein? Ach, das ist ein Stack Over, eigentlich eine coole Sache, oder? Eigentlich ist das eine coole Sache, eigentlich mega nice.
So was, so was bräuchten wir bei mir auf der Arbeit auch, anstatt 50 Knowledge Base Systeme, wo keiner mehr durchblickt, aber bei uns auf der Arbeit neue Sachen zu etablieren, ist ja eine Lebensaufgabe und da bin ich nicht berufen für.
Also, wenn man denkt, die Bürokratie ist schlimm für den Fahrradweg hier, die Bürokratie bei mir auf der Arbeit übertrifft das noch mehr, die sind super bürokratisch.
Oh, was ist das? The cutest Discord Client Mod. Okay, Leute, das war's für uns. Da können die ganzen Weebs jetzt hier anrücken. Also, cutest Discord Client. Ich seh schon, wo ist der Sebaro, wenn man ihn braucht? Der Sebaro hat das bestimmt schon.
Das wollte ich mir angucken. Wenncord.
Ich seh schon hier. Hypercute Discord Mod. Aber das finde ich auch ein ganz cooles Projekt.
Interessiert nicht. Interessiert nicht. Was? A suite of high performance tools for Java. Written in... Was? Was sonst? Written in Rust, blazingly fast. Wo sind die Krustentiere hier wieder? Was soll das sein? Ich weiß überhaupt nicht, was das sein soll überhaupt.
Ich weiß gar nicht, was ist das überhaupt? Kann man damit Standalone-Java-Skript-Dinger erstellen? Es ist blazingly fast while written in Rust, aber was macht das überhaupt? Das manchmal würde ich mir wünschen bei irgendwelchen Projekten, wenn man einfach mal so zwei, drei Sätze dazu stehen hätte, was es ist.
Ich meine, the Oxidation Compiler. Was? Hier. Parser, Linter, Formatter, Transpiler, Minifier, Resolver. All written in Rust. Okay, und warum? Warum sollte ich das verwenden? Ich meine, es ist nicht so, dass der Buildstep und so irgendwie großartig... Naja. Egal. While written in Rust. Schadet ja nix.
Ja, ey. Ruff. Ey. Jeder scheißt hier den Rust rewritten gerade. Es gibt sogar mittlerweile DF rewritten in Rust wahrscheinlich, denke ich mal. Ja. Natürlich. DF written in Rust. Was sonst? Ich frage mich, wann sie Rust in Rust rewriten. Ja, genau.
Was ist das? Irgendwelches China-Chinesen-Zeug? Okay. What the fu... Ist das das China-Chinesen-Spotify oder sowas? China-Spotify? Ich weiß es nicht. Ich verstehe... Okay, Moment, Moment.
Google Translate. Wobei, nee, das ging doch hier irgendwie. Englisch. Äh, Deutsch? Äh. Die Zielsprache muss ausgewählt werden, Google, man. Diese Webseite ist nicht auf Englisch. Diese Seite... Was? Ist es Chinesisch oder Japanisch? Keine Ahnung. Japanisch? Probieren wir das mal.
Okay, es scheint Japanisch zu sein. Eine Basis für Elektron plus View. Es ist der Rakuyuki Otoki Assistent Box Version. Alles klar, jetzt wissen wir Bescheid. Das ist bestimmt irgendein japanischer Musik-Streaming-Service, würde ich jetzt mal vermuten, ja. Ohne es zu wissen.
Kann DeepL komplette Webseiten übersetzen? Oder braucht man da eine Extension für... Äh. Keine Ahnung. Was hat man sonst noch? Copy-Paste? Nee. Extreme-Firmware, das ist wieder was für einen 3D-Drucker.
Nee, mein Flipper... Ich bring das immer durch. Der Flipper Zero ist dieses Wifi-Analyse-Hacking-Ding, oder? Und Clipper ist die 3D-Drucker-Firmware. Was macht die Bahn hier? Ach nee, Database. Das ist schon schlimm, oder? Wenn das erste, woran du bei DB denkst, die Bahn ist und keine Database.
Okay, diese Woche ist nicht sonderlich spannend. Aber eigentlich ganz cool, wir haben zwei Sachen gefunden, die man sich mal angucken kann. Nicht, dass da, wenn Quart... Ganz wichtig, muss ich nachher unbedingt ausprobieren. Ich brauche den cutesten Discord überhaupt. Und das hier finde ich eine richtig coole Sache, aber das ist bei mir auf der Arbeit hoffnungslos, sowas einzuführen.
Ja, jaja, geht halbwegs wieder. Das meiste ist weg. Leider ist mein Fahrrad im Arsch. Wie im Arsch habe ich gemerkt, seitdem ich es auf den Heimtrainer hier geschnallt habe, dass die Schaltung gar nicht mehr richtig geht.
Warum ist Rust so gehyped? Tja, ich glaube, das hat mehrere Gründe. Rust ist seit Jahren schon gehyped, darf man nicht vergessen. Das liegt zum ersten Mal daran... Also, es ist tatsächlich gar nicht so einfach zu sagen. Es liegt, glaube ich, einmal an Rust selber und es liegt an dem Kult, der um Rust mittlerweile existiert.
Den es aber gar nicht gegeben hätte, hätte Rust nicht was richtig gemacht. Also, ich denke mal, aus Rusts Sicht hat es schon ein paar ganz coole Sachen, die auch ziemlich, wie sagt man, waren so neu... Wie heißt das auf Deutsch so? Neu...
Die Sachen gemacht haben, die vorher sonst kaum einer gemacht hat und in Kombination. Innovativ, ja. Was heißt Novelty denn so? Neuheit, ja. Die es halt besonders neu gemacht hat.
Und zwar, Rust ist an sich im Kern eine unmanaged Sprache. Das heißt also, da ist im Hintergrund keine Memory, Garbage Collection und auch kein automatisches Memory Management dahinter.
Trotzdem musst du dich so gut wie nie um manuelles Memory Management kümmern und du kannst dir bei vielen Sachen zur Compile Zeit schon sicher sein, dass sie so funktionieren werden, wie du es gebaut hast.
Das heißt nicht, dass du nicht Fehler bauen kannst, aber es ist tatsächlich in Rust gar nicht so einfach kaputte Sachen zu bauen, weil Rust hat relativ viele Compile Time Checks, was die Lebenszeit von Variablen...
Ich versuche es mal ganz grob zu umschreiben. Also was die Lebenszeit von Variablen und nennen wir es mal Objekte angeht. Also wo in der kompletten Managed Sprache das alles getrackt ist.
Also du kannst ja in der Managed Sprache gar nicht so sagen, lass mal kurz ein bisschen Speicher anfordern und dann sagst du, ich gebe den einfach nicht frei. Das passiert im Hintergrund alles für dich.
Bei vielen Sprachen kannst du es trotzdem machen. Bei Rust ist es so, Rust trackt die theoretisch mögliche Lifetime von Sachen, die du angelegt hast und sagt dir, wenn du sie nicht richtig aufräumst bzw. wenn du sie nicht richtig benutzt.
Also zum Beispiel, wenn du in Rust eine Variable anlegst, die out of scope geht oder nicht klar ist, welcher Teil des Programms dafür zuständig ist, dass die am Ende aufgeräumt wird, dann lässt es dich schlicht und ergreifend nicht kompilieren.
Das heißt, Rust verbindet quasi so ein bisschen die Geschwindigkeit von C mit ein bisschen mehr Memory Safety und Sicherheitsfeatures zu Compile Zeit, dass du dir nicht so leicht in den Fuß schießen kannst und nicht so leicht Sicherheitslücken produzieren kannst.
Das heißt, Rust ist richtig gut für solche Sachen wie zum Beispiel eine CSS Engine für einen Browser, was übrigens auch der erste Anwendungszweck war, weil das Ganze wurde von Mozilla entwickelt und das sind ja die mit Firefox.
Also für sicherheitskritische Anwendungen, die trotzdem Peak Performance brauchen sozusagen. Dafür ist Rust gut.
Was man mit Rust allerdings auch ein bisschen einfängt und das wollen die Rust Leute zwar nicht wahrhaben, aber meiner Meinung nach ist das so, auch dass man nicht so hohe Developer Produktivität in Kauf nimmt.
Ich finde, Rust ist nicht sonderlich produktiv schreibbar, programmierbar und auch nicht sonderlich gut lesbar.
Das kann man aber in Kauf nehmen, wenn man eine Anwendung baut, die eben genau in diesem Bereich sich abspielt. Du brauchst super krasse Performance, aber das Ganze ja so sicher wie möglich noch, was Memory Safety angeht.
Ist natürlich bei vielen Programmen gar nicht notwendig. Wenn du sagen willst, nimm mal zum Beispiel Spiele. Spiele brauchen krasse Performance, aber der Rest ist nicht so wichtig. Im schlimmsten Fall crasht dir das Game.
Im schlimmsten Fall crasht dir das Game. Wenn wir jetzt beispielsweise von irgendeiner Sandbox im Browser reden, die muss schnell sein, die muss aber auch so sein, dass nicht irgendjemand aus der Sandbox aussprechen kann.
Das ist wirklich so ein guter Punkt für Rust. Und sicherlich wird das besser, umso besser man in Rust wird, was die Developer Produktivität angeht. Aber trotzdem ist das, finde ich, so eines mit, dass Rust auch eklig lesbar ist, gerade wenn es die Leute keine Mühe geben.
Also Rust hat gefühlt mehr Sonderzeichen als C++ und das heißt schon was. Teilweise mehr Klammern als Erlang. Und dadurch, dass das eben so neuartig war in diesem Ansatz, quasi so sicher wie möglich, aber ohne Performance Kompromisse, hat es so einen gewissen Kult aufgebaut um sich, Rust.
Und die sind doch überall aktiv, wo es um Programmiersprachen geht. Sei es auf YouTube oder sei es auf Hacker News oder auf Reddit. Du hast immer, wenn irgendwo irgendwas ist, so ein paar von der Rust Task Force, die da aufploppen und den Leuten erzählen, oh mit Rust wäre das nicht passiert und das ist der Grund, warum ich nur noch Rust verwende.
Seit drei Jahren nur noch Rust und das gibt keine Probleme mehr. Ihr habt diese Comments wahrscheinlich auch schon überall gesehen. Und das sind diese zwei Dinge. Also einmal macht Rust Sachen wirklich neuartig und auch sehr innovativ für bestimmte Bereiche und das lohnt sich dann auch Rust zu verwenden.
Aber so dieses Gehype und dieses Kult-Following um Rust, es tut nochmal sein Übriges dabei. Und deswegen gibt es glaube ich auch so viele Leute, die ihre Programme in Rust schreiben, die man eigentlich gar nicht bräuchte.
Warum muss ich ein DF re-implementen in Rust oder warum muss ich ein, ja keine Ahnung, was gibt es denn sonst noch als Echo wahrscheinlich. Ey Leute, passt mal auf. Echo, Rust, es gibt bestimmt Echo re-implement, ja ja.
Okay, ja, also das ist, weil es geht, das ist, weil es geht und, und weil es sich einfach gut macht. Die Leute schreiben dann immer auf ihre GitHub-Seite so nach dem Motto DF re-implemented in Rust, blazingly fast. Und haben dann instant 5000 GitHub-Sterne.
Im Endeffekt habe ich aber immer den Eindruck, dass dieses re-implemented Zeug in Rust erstens irgendwie kaum jemand wirklich dauerhaft benutzt und zweitens viele, viele der Projekte auch nach einem halben Jahr, wenn die Leute keinen Bock mehr auf Rust haben, einfach wieder untergehen.
Es gibt ein paar Ausnahmen, ja, aber das Ding ist halt, die ganzen Standard-Tools müssen nicht re-implemented werden in Rust und ich sage euch auch warum. Jeder kann sein Zeug re-implementen in Rust, so viel er will und so viel er Bock hat, ist überhaupt kein Problem und man lernt auch was dabei, das ist wirklich gar kein Ding, soll jeder machen, was er will.
Aber das Ding ist halt folgendes, warum ich das nicht für sonderlich sinnvoll halte, Standard-Tools zu re-implementen in Rust. Nehmen wir jetzt mal zum Beispiel sowas wie LS. Jeder auf der Welt, der ein bisschen was mit Linux zu tun hat, weiß so grob wie LS funktioniert.
Ja, so nach dem Motto, LS, ja, Zeug auf Listen im Ordner, LS-LA, das Ganze ein bisschen ausführlicher und das Ganze noch human readable und reverse sortiert nach Datum, nach Änderungsdatum so. Das kann jeder.
Jetzt gibt es zum Beispiel sowas wie Exa, das ist quasi ein fast LS-kompatible Rust-Reimplementierung, die aber nicht ganz kompatibel ist und das Ding ist halt folgendes, diese Standard-Tools, LS, Z, CREB, CREB gibt es ja auch re-implemented in Rust, DF, AWK und so, was es nicht alles gibt, also das, was man zu 90% in irgendwelchen Shell-Scripts und interaktiv auf der Kommandozeile verwendet,
die gibt es halt schon lange, man hat sich dran gewöhnt, wie die Dinger funktionieren und niemand hat auf einem Remote-System die Rust-Implementierung davon installiert.
Es bringt mir überhaupt nichts, wenn ich irgendwie ein LS habe, was written in Rust ist und super tolle krasse Features habe und ich mich daran gewöhnt habe, dass ich jetzt, keine Ahnung, LS minus das machen kann und dann kommt was ganz geiles bei raus, wenn es LS auf dem Remote-System das nicht hat.
Also ich bin der Meinung, man fährt ganz gut, wenn die Standard-Tools wirklich lokal und remote auch die Standard-Tools sind. Wir reden hier wirklich von den Basic-Sachen, CD, LS, CREB, Z, AWK, also die Basic-Sachen, die müssen nicht re-implemented in Rust sein.
Niemand hat auf dem Remote-System die re-implemented Sachen in Rust drauf und wenn man sich daran gewöhnt, ist es sogar schon ein bisschen nervig, weil du dann zum Beispiel sagst LS minus das da und stellst, oder was auch immer das sein soll, Poash, ja, geht nicht.
Ich habe einfach face-rolled auf der Tastatur gerade und deine Rust-Implementierung macht dann was krasses, wenn du LS minus Poash machst, aber die Standard-Implementierung macht nichts und deswegen finde ich, ist das fast schon ein bisschen kontraproduktiv, die Basic-Tools in Rust re-written zu verwenden.
Und ich finde auch, dass genau dort Rust eigentlich nicht seine Stärken hat in solchen Tools, aber jeder kann ja re-writen und machen, was da lustig ist. Ja, wahrscheinlich.
3 Monate fachinformatische Anwendungsausbildung hinter mir. Mach mal in 3 Wochen Kobol gelernt, viel mit Kursgeld. Ja, das ist am Anfang, am Anfang ist immer sehr viel was auf einen einprasselt, weil es ja nicht nur die ersten 3 Monate sind, wo du jetzt dich mit der Technik auseinandersetzt, sondern auch 3 Monate ganz viel Neues.
Viele Leute waren vorher noch nie in der IT tätig, haben noch nie was gearbeitet, müssen sich erstmal ein bisschen mit den Leuten auseinandersetzen, mit den Geflogenheiten und Gegebenheiten in der Firma. Also die ersten 3 Monate dürften wahrscheinlich mit Abstand des Anstrengens zu sein. Danach wird das alles ein bisschen entspannter, macht dir mal keine Gedanken. Ab jetzt, ab jetzt wird es eigentlich nur noch entspannter.
Ja, man kann sich Mühe geben, aber Rust ist halt sehr Sonderzeichen lastig. Ja gut, wenn ich von C++ kommen würde, würde ich wahrscheinlich auf alles abfahren, weil schlechter kann es ja nimmer werden.
Kennst du eine gute Seite, wo man programmieren lernen kann? Es gibt jede Menge. Ja, ich wollte auch gerade sagen, guck dir Youtube Tutorials an. Such dir vor allem erstmal eine Sprache und Technik raus, mit der du anfangen willst. Wenn du keine Ahnung hast, oh ne, bloß nicht. Das ist, die sind doch auch schon, da steht doch auch schon immer, wenn du HTML Sachen nachgucken willst, irgendein Mist.
Achso, okay, das ist doch keine Scam-Seite. Kenn ich nicht. Also wenn du gar keine Ahnung hast, mit was du anfangen willst, dann ist tatsächlich aus meiner Sicht das einfachste, installier dir Visual Studio Code und bastel ein bisschen mit Javascript, HTML und CSS rum.
Weil Javascript ist eine Sprache, die begleitet dich mehr oder weniger, wahrscheinlich dein ganzes Entwicklerleben, immer mal mehr und mal weniger und immer mal wieder. Es sei denn, du wirst irgendwann wirklich Frontend-Entwickler, weil dir das gut gefällt. Es ist ein großes Feld, werden auch viele gesucht und macht sicherlich auch Bock, wenn einem das gefällt.
Machen ja sehr viele. Dann hast du natürlich noch mehr Javascript. Aber das, was du gelernt hast, so die Basics in Javascript, bringen dir natürlich auch in jeder anderen Sprache was. Ja, wenn du gelernt hast, wie du eine Schleife machst, wie du irgendwie einen Switch machst, einen If machst, einen Array anlegst und sowas.
Klar, das ist immer ein bisschen unterschiedlich pro Sprache, aber so von den Konzepten her bringt dir das was. Und zum Einstieg ist es halt mit Abstand am einfachsten, einfach sich Visual Studio Code zu installieren, HTML-Seite zu erstellen und da ein bisschen Javascript reinzuhauen. Und du siehst visuell auch gleich was, was passiert. Also ich kann dir nur empfehlen, fang mit Javascript, HTML und CSS an.
Es sei denn, du hast schon was... Lukas, hast du denn schon irgendwas im Kopf, was du machen willst? Wenn du was Spezielles im Kopf hast, dann ist es natürlich sinnvoll, auch damit anzufangen, was dir da was bringt. Ja, also wenn du jetzt sagst, ich würde gerne eine Windows-Desktop-Anwendung erstellen. Ich hoffe nicht, dass es das ist, aber es gibt ja Leute, die wollen das machen.
Dann ist jetzt vielleicht Javascript, CSS, HTML nicht unbedingt das Beste, wobei dank Elektron geht das ja mittlerweile auch. Wenn Hello World 500 MB RAM brauchen soll, aber man hat ja heutzutage genug RAM. Wenn du das machen willst, würde ich dir was anderes empfehlen. Wenn du nur Linux-Commando-Zeilentools entwickeln möchtest, dann ist vielleicht Go nicht verkehrt.
Also, du musst wissen, was du vorhast. Ansonsten, wenn du es nicht weißt, dann Javascript, CSS, HTML und Texteditor Browser. Fertig, los geht's. Einstiegshürde ist einfach am geringsten.
If-Schleifen sind prinzipiell am besten. Ich verwende eigentlich nur noch If-Schleifen. Wie synchronisierst du verschiedene Settings? Gar nicht, ehrlich gesagt. Ich habe einen .files-Repo auf GitHub, da habe ich aber nicht meine JetBrains-Settings drin. Ich habe aber auch gar nicht so viele Sachen in meinen JetBrains-IDE eingestellt. Und wenn ich mal irgendwo an einer neuen Kiste bin, stelle ich die 5-6 Sachen halt so mal schnell von Hand ein.
Also, lass mal überlegen. Was habe ich in meinen JetBrains-IDE eingestellt? Meine Schriftart, die Schriftgröße, ich habe eingestellt, dass Zeile hoch, Zeile runter moven. Also Shortcuts, Zeile hoch, Zeile runter moven. Ich weiß gar nicht, was sonst noch.
Farbschema, Farbschema habe ich eingestellt, habe ich immer das, überall das Rider Dark, auch hier nicht Rider, habe ich Rider Dark. Ansonsten bin ich mir gar nicht so sicher, was ich noch. Achso, Undo, Redo habe ich Shortcuts umgelegt, weil manchmal sind die so ganz merkwürdig platziert.
Aber ansonsten, ich glaube, das war es eigentlich. Ja, da lässt aber auch kein Elektron laufen. Also man hat auf dem Desktop eigentlich mehr oder weniger genug RAM, auch für 1, 2, 3, 4, 5 Elektronen-Anwendungen.
Guck mal, ich meine, guck mal hier. 20G von 63G. Und ganz ehrlich, von diesen 20G ist die Hälfte auch nicht belegt. Sinnig? Das ist meine VM, ein Großteil davon ist meine VM, die selbst 24G hat.
Und wenn ich die VM beende, dann ist das Memory wahrscheinlich, ja, dann ist es 12 und davon ist wahrscheinlich auch noch nicht mal wirklich richtig viel in use, sondern ganz viel so pre, pre, ja wie nennt man das so, so allocated, dass es schneller geht. Also kannst du vergessen.
Wahrscheinlich brauche ich gerade irgendwie 6G RAM oder so, die notwendig wären. Und das meiste davon braucht wahrscheinlich meinen Browser, weil ich ein bisschen viele Tabs auf habe. Meinung zum neuen Teams, ich habe es noch nicht verwendet. Auf der Arbeit haben wir, wer hätte das gedacht, bei uns dauert sowas immer 30, 30 Jahre, bis sich das ändert.
Aber noch Teams Classic. Es ist lahmes Fuck wie vorher, aber ganz brauchbar. Übrigens, ich habe ja die ganze Zeit immer nur Teams gelobt. Ich habe ja immer gesagt, Leute, ich verstehe dieses Gehate gegen Teams nicht, guckt euch mal die Alternativen an, sowas wie Zoom zum Beispiel oder noch schlimmer, was man früher hatte, Skype oder ganz schlimm, Webex, falls irgendjemand Cisco Webex mal verwenden musste.
Dagegen ist Teams doch eigentlich ganz gut. Und ja, ich denke immer noch, dass Teams insgesamt tatsächlich gar nicht übel ist. Eine Sache ist mir jetzt aber aufgefallen, die in Teams richtig kacke ist. Aber richtig kacke. Teams ist super krass closed.
Die haben zwar eine, wie heißt das, Craft API oder sowas. Kannst du machen, wenn deine Firma die passende Infrastruktur dafür hat. Dann geht das. Habe ich aber noch nie aufgesetzt, das geht aber.
Und du kannst es komplett vergessen, Teams irgendwie api-technisch anzusprechen. Das ist einfach nicht möglich, richtig. Also wenn du jetzt beispielsweise sagst, hey, ich würde gern, also warum ich mich damit beschäftigt habe ist, also zumindest mir das mal kurz angeguckt habe ist, wir haben bei uns in Teams, haben wir so eine Funktion.
Da kann man festlegen, also mal angenommen, man hat so eine Sammelrufnummer und man möchte die Sammelrufnummer umstellen ab 17 Uhr zum Beispiel auf eine bestimmte Nummer und das möchte man abhängig vom Tag machen halt an denjenigen, der Bereitschaft hat.
So, habe ich mir überlegt, wäre es nicht cool, wenn man das über die API machen könnte, ganz automatisch. Man guckt einfach nach, wer Bereitschaft hat und lässt es automatisch umstellen ab 17 Uhr. Leute, keine Chance, unmöglich.
Über Teams selbst geht das, du kannst in Teams, kannst du auf Settings gehen, auf Sammelrufnummer und dann irgendwie auf Weiterleiten, so überhaupt kein Problem, aber über irgendeine API, über irgendeinen Service, unmöglich, geht nicht, kannst du komplett vergessen.
Und die Teams APIs überhaupt so zu nennen ist schon ein Witz, du kannst es vergessen. Was du machen kannst eventuell mit sehr viel Glück ist, du könntest eine Teams App entwickeln, die man dann über den Teams App Store installieren kann, aber das bringt dir dann auch nichts. Es ist komplett für den Arsch. Also so Programmierschnittstellen ist für Teams komplett Kacke, richtig mega scheiße.
Der Rest ist aber ganz brauchbar. Ja, was du machen kannst ist, du kannst Desktop Automatisierung benutzen, ja. Klicke jetzt dahin, klicke jetzt dahin, klicke jetzt dahin. Also du müsstest zum Beispiel dir eine VM installieren, wo immer alles exakt gleich groß ist und dann kannst du da in Teams klicken. Ja, das würde eventuell vielleicht funktionieren.
Nö, nö. Könnte man, könnte man vielleicht machen, ja. Aber ich gehe davon aus, dass die, das ist ja dann keine offiziellen API-Geschichten, das sind ja so inoffizielle Sachen von Microsoft, dass sich das auch öfters ändert und du garantiert allein schon für die Authentifizierung wieder einen Riesenakt machen musst. Also ich glaube, das ist kein richtig gangbarer Weg.
Du kannst in Teams das steuern, aber nicht irgendwie programmiertechnisch. Das ist halt das Problem. So, jetzt machen wir das hier mal zu. Das machen wir auch mal zu. So, was können wir uns denn heute mal anschauen? Was ist das? MyDeals. Die haben einen YouTube-Channel? Ey, weißt du was? Das ist eine ziemlich gute Idee.
So was wie Script Monkey oder wie das, nee, wie heißt das? Monkey Script oder? Da gibt es doch so ein Browser-Automatisierungs-Plugin. Brauchst halt auch eine extra VM, wo du das installierst drin, dass du die Rechte hast, aber ja. Temper Monkey, nee, wie heißt denn das neue? Es heißt weder Crease Monkey, das alte Temper Monkey. Wie heißt denn das? Es gibt doch ein neues. Das haben wir doch hier im Stream auch schon verwendet.
Violent Monkey. Ja, das ist die neueste Ausgabe davon. Ja, aber ernsthaft, alles, wo man irgendwie Desktop-Automatisierung machen muss, sag doch. Also alles, wo du irgendwie rumklicken musst oder so. Mausklick simulieren, das ist halt richtig Müll.
Was ist das hier? Internets-Anschluss? Gibt es eigentlich noch Arche Internets oder wie die hießen? Da gab es doch mal so eine Fake-Seite vor zig Jahren, die auch so besonders christlich gemacht haben. Kennt das noch irgendjemand Arche Internets oder wie das hieß? Oder wie hieß das denn?
Irgend so eine Fake-Seite, die so auf superchristlich gemacht hat und alle Anglizismen verboten hat oder nicht schreiben wollte. Sprich, die haben nicht Internetsurfen gesagt, die haben Internets-Stehsegeln dann immer geschrieben und sowas. Das war richtig Cringe-Shit damals. Internets-Stehsegler.
Okay, was ist das hier? Kostenloses Internet von GigaFiber. Wo ist der Haken? Okay, GigaFiber. GigaFiber, nicht GigaChat. GigaFiber. Okay, das gucken wir uns tatsächlich mal an. Ich kenne den YouTube-Channel von MyDeals nicht. Also keine Ahnung, ob die Videos was taugen, aber werden wir jetzt gleich sehen.
Kostenloses Internets von GigaFiber. Golem, okay. GigaFiber. Gucken wir mal, was Golem dazu sagt. Wir gucken uns einfach das Video an.
Internetanschluss, der dauerhaft komplett kostenlos ist. Das klingt erstmal viel zu gut, um wahr zu sein, aber der Anbieter GigaFiber.
Obwohl es erstmal kostenlos aussieht. Ich bin da mittlerweile sehr skeptisch, was sowas angeht. Generell, wenn dir einer was schenken will, ist es immer verdächtig.
GigaFiber verspricht ganz genau das. Wir haben uns das Ganze mal ein bisschen genauer angeschaut, unter anderem auch einen Blick drauf geworfen, wer denn da überhaupt dahinter steckt und erklären euch, warum das Ganze nicht ohne Haken ist, obwohl es in der Werbung eigentlich so versprochen wird.
Ja, wer hätte das gedacht? Ja, am Dienstag haben wir erstmal alle nicht schlecht gestaunt, als der Anbieter GigaFiber irgendwie komplett aus dem Nichts aufgetaucht ist und direkt mal mit einem Deal auf der Plattform gelandet ist.
Der Deal ist ehrlicherweise kalt geworden und das hat auch einen gewissen Grund, denn das Versprechen klingt erstmal eigentlich komplett unglaubwürdig. Der Deal ist kalt geworden, das ist auch ein geiler Satz, Alter.
Es wird damit geworben, dass ein Internetanschluss dauerhaft komplett kostenlos ist. Das heißt, es wird euch eine Glasfaserleitung zu Hause komplett kostenlos hingelegt, ihr kriegt einen kostenlosen Router gestellt und ihr zahlt auch für den monatlichen Tarif 0 Euro.
Und zum ersten Punkt muss man direkt sagen, das ist definitiv möglich, dass der Ausbau an sich gratis erfolgt, denn es gibt staatliche Förderungen und Telekom etc. gehen auch hin und bauen auch aus in Gebieten, wo entsprechend viele Interessenten vorhanden sind.
Sie streichen dann die staatliche Förderung ein und ihr kriegt am Ende dann als derjenige, der da wohnt oder dem das Haus gehört, einen kostenlosen Anschluss bis zumindest mal bei euch in den Keller und könnt euch dann entscheiden, ob ihr einen entsprechenden Tarif habt.
Kommen dann irgendwelche nicht gut ausgebildeten tschechischen Monteure über Nacht, die dir das in den Keller hämmern oder so? Das ist bestimmt super shady allein schon an der Stelle.
Aber beim zweiten Punkt, da wird es dann natürlich deutlich unglaubwürdiger erstmal, denn wie soll das funktionieren, dass der Internetanschluss an sich dauerhaft kostenlos ist?
Da geht der Anbieter Gigafiber hin und sagt auch selber schon relativ präsent auf seiner Seite, es gibt eine Voraussetzung dafür, dass dieser Tarif wirklich nichts kostet, denn damit wir das dauerhaft kostenlos anbieten können, musst du, lieber Kunde, ein sogenanntes Payment Service Agreement mit einem unserer Partner unterschreiben.
Und über den wickelst du dann künftig deine wiederkehrenden Zahlungen ab, wie zum Beispiel die Monatsmiete oder Stromvertrag oder sonstige Dinge, die regelmäßig kosten.
Ah ja, ok, und die wollen dann Transaktionsgebühren oder irgendwas an irgendeiner Stelle?
Das sind dann wahrscheinlich super shady Bezahlanbieter. Payment.eu oder sowas. Ich weiß nicht, ob es das gibt, aber im Zweifelsfall schon. Mail.eu Paying oder so. PayPal Mail.eu.
Ich sage, also die Werbung, die passt da nicht drunter.
Oder Punkt, ist CN die Top Level Domain von China? Oder ist das für, ja ich glaube schon CN. Payment.cn.
Denn die wirbt mit 0 Euro 0 Stress und 0 Haken. 0 Euro stimmt dann wohl, aber 0 Stress kann ich nicht einschätzen. 0 Haken zumindest nicht, denn klar ist das ein Haken, wenn man sagt, hey, es müssen künftig irgendwie gewisse Zahlungen darüber abgewickelt werden.
Thematisch an der Sache ist, selbst wenn man sich ein bisschen in die AGB eingräbt auf der Webseite, es steht nirgends klar drin, zum einen, wer ist überhaupt dieser Zahlungsdienstleister, mit dem ich da einen separaten Vertrag abschließen muss.
Das steht nämlich durchaus in den AGB drin, also dass also ein separater Vertrag aufgesetzt werden muss mit diesem Zahlungsanbieter.
Einen von uns benannten Zahlungsanbieter in Anspruch zu nehmen. Okay, das heißt im Endeffekt, das ist Lückentext. Die können da irgendwas einsetzen, was sie wollen. Und wenn sie jetzt meinen, du musst Krypto-Scam-Anbieter aus Bangladesch nehmen oder wo auch immer, dann musst du das machen.
Aber es werden halt wirklich auch nur Beispiele genannt, was theoretisch an Zahlungen darüber laufen könnte. Es wird gesagt, dass das Ganze für dich als Kunde kostenlos sein soll. Es wird aber irgendwo nirgends erklärt, die Frage, die ich mir stelle, warum sollte denn mein...
Wisst ihr, ich hab die FiveHat-Idee überhaupt richtig ausgetribbelt jetzt. Wenn Telekom und Vodafone und so bei dir nicht Glasfaser ausbauen, dann lässt du einfach von GigaFiber dir eine Glasfaserkabel in den Keller legen und dann kündigst du den Vertrag und benutzt nie den Zahlungsdienstleister.
Dann schmeißen die dich raus, aber du hast ein Glasfaser im Keller und dann lässt du dich vom ordentlichen Anbieter anschließen. Aber das wird wahrscheinlich nicht funktionieren, weil sie da wahrscheinlich schon dran gedacht haben. In irgendeiner Art und Weise werden die sich das schon überlegt haben.
... sich überhaupt darauf einlassen, dass die Miete künftig nicht mehr von meinem Konto überwiesen wird, sondern von irgendeinem externen Anbieter, der sich dazwischen klemmt und der ja auch in irgendeiner Form mitverdienen möchte. Also das erschließt sich mir zumindest auf Basis der Datenlage, die wir aktuell haben und wir nehmen hier am Mittwoch, den 25.10. auf, nicht wirklich wie dieser Payment-Service-Provider im Hintergrund da tatsächlich gedenkt Geld zu verdienen, weil irgendwie muss es sich wieder finanzieren.
Das kann man aber sagen, muss ja als Kunde nicht unbedingt mein Problem sein und wie kann ich mich denn überhaupt dafür antragen? Und das ist der zweite Punkt, wo es so ein bisschen seltsam wird, denn offiziell wird damit geworben, dass man sich erstmal die App runterladen soll. Also es gibt tatsächlich im App-Store eine App von GigaFiber.
Das ist halt schon so ein Ding, ich würde mir noch nicht mal diese App aufs Handy lassen.
Das soll Vertrauen irgendwie vermitteln aus der TV-Werbung ZDF. Ich gehe ganz stark davon aus, dass sie nicht sich das eingeholt haben vom ZDF das Logo verwenden zu dürfen. Ich weiß auch nicht, ob man das muss, wenn man drausschreibt aus der TV-Werbung.
Das ist ja nicht gelogen, aber allein schon, weil da ZDF-Logo drunter ist, schafft das für Oma und Opa Vertrauen.
GigaFiber, die macht momentan nichts anderes, als dass ich damit einfach einen Antrag abschicken kann. Also ich bekunde quasi über die App Interesse daran, dass bitte bei mir Glasfaser ausgebaut werden soll.
Klar gibt es Werbung auf ZDF.
Und wenn sich das dann irgendwann ergibt, dann kriege ich über die App eine Push-Benachrichtigung und werde dann informiert, dass das bei mir möglich ist und kann dann das Angebot annehmen.
Das ist insofern auch nicht zu beanstanden.
Klar gibt es Werbung im öffentlich-rechtlichen Fernsehen. Ich glaube erst ab 20 Uhr nicht mehr.
Über eine App zu machen, weil wenn es einfach nur ein Antrag ist, wozu brauche ich da eine App? Und tatsächlich, wenn ich über den Desktop die Seite aufrufe.
Doch, die machen Werbung. Ganz normale Werbung.
Und auf quasi die App klicke, lande ich auch gar nicht bei der App, sondern bei einem stinknormalen Formular, wo ich das irgendwie auch mitmachen kann. Also was diese App so genau soll, erschließt sich noch nicht ganz.
Ja Moment. Doch, die sind erstmal auf deinem Handy drauf. Das ist wahrscheinlich das Interessante für die.
Wahrscheinlich werden darüber dann später mal die Zahlungen abgewickelt. Kommen wir aber gleich noch zu. Dann kommen wir mal zu dem Web-Auftritt dieses neuen Anbieters.
Wisst ihr was auch sein kann? Alles nur Vermutung, dass sie wollen, dass die Leute das darüber abschließen, die die Leute dann scammen mit irgendwelchen Zahlungsanbietern-Tricks und nie im Keller überhaupt jemals ein Glasfaseranschluss gelegt wird.
Man weiß ja nie, was da so abgeht, ja?
Die Seite des Anbieters sieht erstmal sehr, sehr gut gemacht aus. Und die sind auch zeitgleich mit ihrem Web-Auftritt auf YouTube live gegangen mit einem eigenen Kanal, wo mehrere Erklärvideos stehen, die halt so gewisse Themen behandeln.
Die sind auch alle wirklich gut produziert. Das offizielle Werbevideo, was anscheinend sogar auf dem ZDF lief, zumindest einmal, dass die unten irgendwie damit werben können.
Das sieht wirklich hochprofessionell aus. Also da ist tatsächlich Geld reingeflossen. Also macht erstmal einen ganz guten Eindruck.
Aber wenn man mal ein bisschen näher hinhört, was denn überhaupt in diesen Videos kommuniziert wird, dann kann man zumindest an gewissen Punkten skeptisch werden.
Vor allem, wenn man das dann abgleicht mit dem, was letztlich in den AGB steht.
Ich habe euch da mal so ein paar Punkte zusammengefasst. Unter anderem wird da gesagt in einem Video, es würde sich um ein komplett neues Netz entlang der Infrastruktur der Deutschen Bahn handeln.
Komplett neues Netz, behaltet das gerne im Hinterkopf. Dann wird noch gesagt, es sei ein unabhängiges Netz, was geschützt vor Ausfällen und Hackerangriffen ist.
Ja, ich verstehe, Werbung übertreibt auch gerne mal, aber das ist halt faktisch einfach nicht möglich.
Also jeder, der sich so ein bisschen auskennt mit IT-Infrastruktur, der weiß, es gibt kein ausfallsicheres Netz, gegen Hackerangriffe geschützt.
Naja, war ganz einfach abgesehen. Für die reine Infrastruktur. Also, was hat es damit zu tun?
Ehrlicherweise keine Ahnung, wie sie dieses Versprechen einlösen wollen. Kommt gleich noch ein Punkt, wo es vielleicht darauf anspielt.
Aber auch das, in dem Moment, wo du irgendwie ans normale Internet angeboten bist und wir nicht von irgendeinem fernen internen Netzwerk reden oder so.
Natürlich bist du auch grundsätzlich vor Hackerangriffen nicht komplett geschützt.
Okay, aber mal selbst angenommen, dass jetzt wirklich dieses flächendeckende Netz da gebaut wird.
Ist das denn überhaupt realistisch, beziehungsweise steht das denn überhaupt so in den AGB drin, dass die wirklich ein komplett neues Netz bauen, was dann auch wirklich von der Schiene entlang bis in dein Haus geht?
So wird es versprochen in der Werbung. Und ne, denn in den AGB steht was drin, was dem in meinen Augen komplett widerspricht.
Ich zitiere mal, die Gigafiber baut in erster Linie in Partnerschaft mit anderen Netzbetreibern aus, verfügt aber selbst auch über eigene Baukapazitäten.
Also, so wie ich das verstehe, würden die wahrscheinlich entlang der Schiene ihr eigenes Netz legen und dann die sogenannte letzte Meile, also quasi von der Schiene dann irgendwie in die einzelnen Häuser,
setzen sie mit Sicherheit auf die bereits vorhandene Infrastruktur, beziehungsweise hoffen halt, dass die Telekom irgendwo die Glasfaserstränge hinzieht oder so.
Ist ja auch eigentlich die sinnvollere Option, denn wozu zweimal den Boden aufbodeln, wenn auch ein Anbieter da schon liegt.
Aber es widerspricht halt dem, was in der Werbung suggeriert wird.
Und in dem Moment, wo ich natürlich die Leitung von jemand anderem mit benutze, habe ich schon kein autarkes Netz mehr und auch der ganze Kram mit Ausfallsicherheit etc., das fällt dann alles raus.
Also die Werbung verspricht da schon mal mehr, als man sich selbst in die AGB schreibt.
Und da hört es noch nicht auf an der Stelle, denn es geht noch weiter.
Die Frage ist, sind die denn überhaupt ein eigener Internetanbieter?
Und da gibt es einen weiteren Punkt, ebenfalls in den AGB, das steht nämlich unter Punkt 2.3a.
Die Leistung wird durch ein Telekommunikationsunternehmen erbracht.
Nach meinem Verständnis wäre das dann zum Beispiel die Telekom, O2, Vodafone oder irgendein anderer Anbieter, der da bereits seine Kabel hingebodelt hat.
Und ganz konkret steht da drin, dass Gigafiber einen Vertrag mit diesem Unternehmen abschließt, für diese Internetleitung und quasi dafür die monatlichen Kosten übernimmt.
Für mich klingt das so, als würden die gar keine eigene Leitung anbieten, sondern einfach den Vertrag eines anderen Anbieters übernehmen und dafür halt die monatlichen Kosten übernehmen.
Auch nicht das, was in der Werbung eigentlich suggeriert wird, nämlich, dass man ein komplett eigenes Netz aufbaut.
Bis jetzt würde ich sagen, ist das noch gar nicht mal so schlimm, solange du dann wirklich auch deinen Glasfaseranschluss kriegst.
Und wo ich mir viel mehr Gedanken drüber machen würde zum aktuellen Zeitpunkt ist, was da mit den Zahlungsanbietern läuft, weil das erscheint mir etwas shady alles.
Was? Du bezahlst bequem über deinen sicheren Router? Hä? Ich dachte, ich muss nichts bezahlen. Oder ich bezahle dann meine Miete über den sicheren Router? Oder was?
Ups, was war das? Das hat halt so einen Schlitz wie einen Geldautomat, der Router.
Tatsächlich funktioniert der Gigafiberrouter während seiner Nutzung wie ein VPN.
Der Router funktioniert wie ein VPN?
Leute, ich muss mir die Werbung von denen jetzt mal kurz im Original angucken. Wie heißen die? Gigafiber. Meint ihr, das ist die Werbung? Ja, oder?
Wir machen Deutschland mit der neu verlegten Glasfaserinfrastruktur schnell, sicher, effizient und zukunftsfähig. Hier wird die Vision zur Realität. Dafür erschaffen wir ein komplett neues Netz.
Verlegen es entlang der Gleise der Deutschen Bahn, bis in die Häuser und Unternehmen. Ein schnelles Netz. Ein sicheres Netz. Ein unabhängiges Netz. Geschützt vor Ausfällen und Hackangriffen. Zusätzlich bauen wir unnötige Bürokratie ab. Digitalisier...
Die Bilder haben damit gar nichts zu tun. Wahrscheinlich sind das irgendwelche Stock-Footage oder so, die ich gekauft habe. Na gut, die Bilder haben damit zu tun, dass es entlang der Deutschen Bahn geht halt.
Keine komplexen Systeme. Die Sicherheit deiner Daten. Ruhe und schnelle Up- und Downloadraten. Effizienz. Genau dafür steht das Gigafiber-Netz. Das Internet wird dich nichts kosten, da wir Bezahlsysteme revolutionieren und damit vereinfachen.
Da wir Bezahlsysteme revolutionieren und damit vereinfachen. Okay, und deswegen ist es kostenlos für mich. Klingt ja super... Perfekt. Komplett schlüssige Begründung, oder? Es ist doch logisch, dass vereinfachte Bezahlsysteme für mich kostenloses Internet bedeuten, oder? Also, obviously. Der Zusammenhang ist doch komplett klar.
Es wird wie die Luft zum Atmen. Selbstverständlich und kostenlos. Wir schenken dir das Internet. Zum Tarif von 0 Euro. Wir sind die Pioniere, die dir den Weg in eine neue, sichere, schnelle und lebenswerte Zukunft bereiten.
Die haben tolle Stock-Videos genommen von Leuten, die in die Luft schauen. Ja, das stimmt. Wir haben gerade erst angefangen. Gigafiber. Das 0-Euro-Internet für alle.
Moment, aber das mit dem VPN und so steht da nicht. Für wen gilt das 0-Euro-Angebot? Das ist ein Troll-Video von Marvin. Ja, das kann durchaus sein.
Das 0-Euro-Internet für alle ist genau das. 0-Euro-Internet für alle. Für Privatpersonen und Unternehmen in Deutschland. Risiko für dich? Keins.
Denn mit dem Ausfüllen des Antrags hast du noch keinen Vertrag unterschrieben und dein bisheriger Anschluss läuft vorerst ganz normal weiter. Also sichere dir jetzt deine Chance auf das 0-Euro-Internet.
Das ist so sass. Wo ist das denn mit diesem VPN-Router? Alter, warum sitzt da einer halbnackig rum? Ich will was mit dem VPN. Wo könnte das dabei sein?
Wir gucken mal, wer im Impressum steht. Falls es da sowas gibt.
Shit, das ist bei mir um die Ecke.
Das ist... Ich habe damit nichts zu tun, Leute.
60329. Das ist direkt an der Brücke. Direkt unter meiner Brücke.
Da, wo man, wenn man ein bisschen weiter geht, dann an dieser Plakette vorbeikommt. Auch hier wurde der erste Euro ausgegeben und sowas.
Wir gucken. Leute, wir gucken mal kurz. Das ist unten am Main. Deswegen gibt es dort wahrscheinlich kein Streetview.
Ach nee. Ah, okay. Das ist nicht unten am Main. Das ist schon die Straße oben. Okay. Wir gucken mal. Wir gucken mal Streetview, ob wir da irgendwas sehen.
Bürofläche zu vermieten. Letztes Jahr im November. Okay. Und vorher war da Nettigate. Interessant. Erkennt ihr da sonst noch was drauf? Nettigate kenne ich nicht.
Aber die sind ja auch hier drin. Genau, hier unten ist der Main. Und hier ist das Bild letztens entstanden am Main. Erkennt ihr es? Das ist das Bild, was ich euch eben auf Twitter gezeigt habe.
Von hier habe ich das Bild gemacht, wo ich mit dem Fahrrad unten am Main war. Nein, nein, nein. Das sind andere. Nicht die PFCents, Leute. Aha, da sind die. Okay.
TikTok. Ja, wenn schon dann gleich richtig. Linktree auch am Start. Pass auf, Onlyfans kommt jetzt gleich. Ja, ein bisschen sus ist das schon alles, gell?
Das wirkt auch so, als hätten die schon 1,135 Millionen Anschlüsse gelegt. Haben sie halt auch nicht. Etwas sus wirkt das alles. Ja, was ist das? Ne. Wo sind wir stehen geblieben? Äh. Ja. Mal weiter gucken.
Und verdienen dann irgendwie an den Daten. Aber das wiederum fällt auch zusammen durch einen anderen Punkt, denn es wird wiederum gesagt, du musst den Router gar nicht nutzen.
Also wir haben ja auch in Deutschland sowas wie Routerfreiheit. Es wird explizit in den AGB geschrieben, du kannst auch einfach deinen eigenen Router nutzen. Okay. Dann funktioniert die ganze Konstellation ja schon mal nicht mehr. Ja. Es sei denn wiederum der Router ist die Voraussetzung für das.
Das ist wahrscheinlich. Wahrscheinlich musst du über die App. Du musst daheim an einem Anschluss mit der App. Ob da jemals überhaupt Anschlüsse geschaltet werden, ist ja noch fraglich.
0 Euro Angebot, das steht da aber so auch nicht drin, sondern da steht nur, du brauchst halt diesen Payment Service Vertrag mit dem anderen Anbieter. Haben wir gesagt, ist nicht näher definiert. Alles wirklich sehr undurchschaubar, wie die überhaupt Geld verdienen möchten.
Das könnte man argumentieren, wenn ich mich da eintrage, schließe ich ja noch keinen Vertrag ab und in dem Moment, wo das möglich ist, kommen da vielleicht weitere Details und ich kann es immer noch dann entscheiden.
Ja, aber ich würde zumindest mal gucken, ist das denn überhaupt realistisch, dass das, was die gerade da irgendwie kommunizieren, dass das in irgendeiner Form auch so umgesetzt wird. Und da warne ich euch jetzt ein bisschen vor, jetzt gehen wir so ein bisschen ins Rabbit Hole.
Kecker-Alu-Time. Kecker-Alu-Time. Wir gehen uns nämlich an, wer steckt überhaupt hinter GIGA Fiber. Erste Anlaufstelle ist natürlich die offizielle Webseite. Wir rufen einfach mal das Impressum auf.
Ja, den habe ich auch schon gefunden. Das habe ich auch gerade gefunden.
Genau in dieser Form, denn es kommen gleich noch ein paar weitere Player ins Spiel, die alle so ein bisschen ähnlich heißen. Da steht auch ein gewisser Herr Jörg Müller als Geschäftsführer im Impressum. Merken wir uns ebenfalls.
Positiv erstmal, diese GIGA Fiber GmbH ist Mitglied in zwei sogenannten Branchenverbänden, wo es um den Breitbandausbau geht. Also da findet man zumindest auf diesen beiden renommierten Websites auch einen Eintrag dazu.
Insofern scheint da schon grundsätzlich so eine Art Vorcheck stattgefunden zu haben. Ich gehe jetzt einfach mal davon aus, dass man sich da nicht irgendwie draufkaufen kann, sondern zumindest mal mit den Herrschaften gesprochen haben muss.
Erstmal ein ganz gutes Indiz. Und da schauen wir jetzt mal genauer hin, wer denn hinter dieser GIGA Fiber GmbH steckt. Und da schauen wir einfach mal ins gute alte Handelsregister, das ist online zu finden.
Und da kann man Informationen zu jedem Unternehmen in Deutschland abrufen. Und wenn ich da in die Suche gehe und einfach mal die GIGA Fiber GmbH eingebe und dann sage bitte genaue Ergebnisse,
dann kriege ich interessanterweise direkt zwei Ergebnisse angezeigt. Nämlich erstmal die GmbH, die ich gesucht habe. Und es gibt auch noch die GIGA Fiber Netz GmbH, die ebenfalls einen Sitz in Frankfurt hat.
Also offenbar in irgendeiner Form eine Schwester-, Tochter-, Klonfirma, whatever ist. Wir schauen uns natürlich erstmal die erste an und da fällt direkt auf, die ist ursprünglich als sogenannte Vorrats GmbH gegründet worden.
Sieht erstmal shady aus, weil das auch so einen generischen Namen hat, ist aber nicht unbedingt ungewöhnlich. Eine sogenannte Vorrats GmbH wird von darauf spezialisierten Firmen quasi als Blanco GmbH gegründet.
Die machen das mehrfach, also legen mehrere dieser GmbHs an, dass sie dann, wenn irgendein Kunde zu ihnen kommt und sagt, ey, ich brauche mal spontan eine GmbH, die quasi schon parat haben, dann wird die einfach nur noch schnell umgeschrieben.
Also kriegt einen anderen Namen, kriegt einen anderen Geschäftsführer. Das geht aber deutlich schneller, als wenn man quasi from scratch eine neue GmbH gründet.
Hat vor allem auch noch den Vorteil, dass die dann auf dem Papier schon länger existiert und Banken gucken da ganz gerne mal hin. Und wie die dann ursprünglich mal hieß, interessiert die nicht.
Das an sich kein Indikator dafür, dass das irgendwie unseriös ist.
Deutlich spannender wird es, wenn man sich anschaut, wer sind denn die Gesellschafter? Und das kann man sich ebenfalls im Handelsregister abrufen.
Und das ist die sogenannte Giga Fiber Optik Products LLC mit Sitz in Dubai.
Da weiß der schon wieder Bescheid, ey.
Passt ja auch, passt ja auch wieder, dass das Ganze in Frankfurt ist.
Frankfurt, Goethe-Straße, Louis Vuitton-Store, zahl die Kollektion bar, fick auf Sponsor.
Sie mit Sitz in Dubai.
Vielleicht hat er apparat was mit zu tun, ja, wer weiß.
Ich als jemand, der sich in der Branche nicht so unbedingt auskennt, bin da zumindest erstmal so ein bisschen stutzig und denke mir, hä, warum ist denn da jemand aus Dubai, der da investieren möchte und der in Deutschland angeblich komplett flächendeckend Glasfaser legen möchte.
Gucken wir aber mal ein bisschen genauer hin, was es mit dieser LLC auf sich hat.
Denn auch in Dubai gibt es ein Handelsregister, wo ich wiederum die Daten eintragen kann.
Und da kriege ich zwei interessante Dinge ausgespuckt.
Zum einen, es handelt sich um eine Ein-Personen-Firma, also das ist kein großes Unternehmen.
Und die Kontakt-E-Mail, die da angegeben ist, ist eine völlig andere.
Und da lande ich auf der Website Aurora Pi, was irgendwie so eine Art Consulting-Firma ist.
Und es ist nicht so ganz genau ersichtlich, was die macht, aber es steht zumindest...
Das ist schon alles ein bisschen sus, ne.
Irgendwie, dass die jetzt großartig mit Breitbandausbau betraut wäre.
Und das ist schon der erste Punkt, wo ich sage, okay, das sind schon ein paar seltsame Verknüpfungen.
Aber da hört es noch nicht auf, denn ich habe ja gerade gesagt, es gibt noch eine zweite GmbH, die fast genau gleich heißt.
Die Gigafiber-Netz-GmbH ist ebenfalls auf einen Herrn Jörg Müller registriert, der im Impressum steht bei der anderen Firma.
Und ist ebenfalls mit dem Gesellschafter aus Dubai verbandelt.
Der einzige Unterschied ist, das war keine Vorrats-GmbH, das heißt, die ist wirklich quasi neu gegründet worden.
Was genau der Hintergrund ist, dass man diese zwei Firmen hat, weiß ich nicht genau.
Vielleicht soll die eine den Ausbau übernehmen, die andere ist nur für die Verwaltung zuständig.
Aber zumindest haben die auch genau die gleiche Satzung, also wirklich wortgleich.
Deswegen für mich auch so ein Punkt, den ich nicht ganz nachvollziehen kann.
Jetzt wird es aber noch eine ganze Spur wilder, denn ich habe noch eine dritte GmbH gefunden über Umwege.
Das ist die sogenannte Giga-Connect-GmbH, der Name also erneut relativ ähnlich.
Da ist alleine schon dieser Werdegang dieser GmbH noch deutlich seltsamer,
denn ursprünglich war das 2021 mal eine Vermögensverwaltung für eine 81-jährige Dame.
Ja genau, ihr habt richtig gehört.
Nach dieser Vermögensgesellschaft ist es dann umgewandelt worden in eine Hilfsorganisation für die Ukraine.
Und nachdem es dann diese Hilfsorganisation für die Ukraine war, ist es umbenannt worden in die Giga-Connect-GmbH.
Es gab natürlich jeweils auch einen Geschäftsführerwechsel.
Und am Ende dieser Kette, also nach dem aktuellen Stand, ist der Geschäftsführer ein gewisser Herr Lars Peter Diebold.
Also nicht unser Herr Jörg Müller.
Jetzt könnte man erneut sagen, okay, das ist ein Zufall, die heißen halt einfach beide so.
Sehr seriös.
Aber wenn man sich mal näher anschaut, was es mit Lars Peter Diebold auf sich hat,
dann findet man relativ schnell seinen LinkedIn-Eintrag.
Und da findet man auch genau das Werbematerial von GigaFiber.
Okay, okay, Moment mal, Leute.
Hier, direkt aus Chat-GPT-Lebenslauf.
Visionary Inventor.
Ja, ja.
Das ist ja...
Schreibe mir ein Business-Stonks-Profil für LinkedIn, Chat-GPT.
I love to build new things that scale fast.
Oh, man, das ist ja 0815-Geschwätze mehr.
Also, mehr leeres Business-Stonks-Gelaber kannst du ja kaum noch machen als den Text hier.
Sustainable win-win-situations.
I do not like to slow down.
Not many words, just actions.
CRM, Big Data, Search Engine, Programming and Implementation, Wi-Fi and Connected.
Das ergibt so überhaupt keinen Sinn zusammen alles.
I'm a defender for free free Internet and media.
Das ist doch Chat-GPT generiert, das Ding, oder?
Der Text ergibt überhaupt keinen Sinn.
Gigafiber, er präsentiert sich da selbst auch als offiziell Gründer von Gigafiber.
Richtiger Macher.
Auch ganz interessant, dass er dann aber nicht im Impressum steht bei Gigafiber.
Und da findet man auch noch so ein paar andere Infos, unter anderem, was sie vorhaben.
Nämlich beispielsweise, dass sie ab dem Januar 2024 mit dem Ausbau beginnen wollen,
bis einschließlich Dezember 2026 und insgesamt 33.000 Kilometer Glasfaser legen wollen.
Das dürfte dann wahrscheinlich dem Schienennetz der Deutschen Bahn entsprechen.
Also grundsätzlich ist dieser Wille also vorhanden.
Wenn wir bei der Giga Connect GmbH dann reinschauen, wer da denn der Gesellschafter ist,
dann ist das ebenfalls eine andere Gesellschaft, die wiederum in Dubai ansässig ist,
mit dem Namen Hi Wi-Fi Connect IT Service.
Ach du Scheiße, da blickt ja keiner mehr durch.
Da kann man auch ein bisschen schauen, wenn man sich auf Herr Diebolds Profil umschaut,
dann findet man relativ schnell die sogenannte International Wi-Fi Connect GmbH,
bei der er auch wiederum als Geschäftsführer eingetragen ist.
Das hört nicht mehr auf.
Also das ist letztlich seine GmbH.
Das Ganze auch in Dubai ansässig, also ebenso wie wohl Herr Diebold zumindest zwischenzeitlich mal.
Entsprechend kann man sagen, dass der eigentliche Charakter hinter dieser Firma Herr Lars-Peter Diebold ist.
Also das scheint auf seine Idee gewachsen zu sein, das Ganze.
Naja, Gelnhausen, der hat ja bis jetzt anscheinend noch nichts verbrochen damit.
Also es ist ja nicht verboten, um verschiedene Unternehmen zu gründen.
Bis jetzt ist das ja noch alles in Ordnung.
Und es muss ja auch gar nicht sein, dass da irgendwie...
Letztendlich muss man ja immer noch sagen, alles nur Vermutungen.
Auch wenn es sehr suspekt ist alles.
Aber laut eigener Firmenreferenz unter anderem in die DB Navigator App und auch in die Samsung Health App integriert ist,
was ja schon relativ große Namen sind.
So weit so gut hat es jetzt erstmal nichts mit Glasfaser zu tun,
aber zumindest mit Internet im weitesten Sinne.
Also die restlichen Referenzen von Herrn Diebold zeigen,
Also er scheint wohl dicke zu sein mit der Bahn.
dass er mit diesem Bereich durchaus Erfahrungen gemacht hat bei verschiedenen Firmen.
Er war unter anderem auch irgendwie in den WLAN Ausbau in den Zügen der Deutschen Bahn involviert.
Also da scheint eine gewisse Vorkenntnis auf jeden Fall vorhanden zu sein.
Und da sieht man unter anderem auch, er hatte auch mal eine Station beim TÜV
und das ist insofern interessant, weil das wieder die Brücke schlägt zum Herrn Jörg Müller.
Denn wenn wir uns mal sein Link im Profil anschauen.
Denn der gute Herr hat einen Großteil seiner beruflichen Laufbahn beim TÜV verbracht.
Das ist ein gut gemachtes Video.
Ich finde die haben da sehr viel nachgebohrt, was da wie wo abgeht.
Unter anderem im Bereich Breitbandausbau.
Die versprechen was sie nicht einhalten, weißt du doch gar nicht.
Bis jetzt ist noch nichts passiert.
Es sieht äußerst verdächtig aus. Ich glaube nicht, dass da was passieren wird.
Auch bis jetzt ist noch nichts passiert.
Also es sind auf jeden Fall Leute involviert, die sich grundsätzlich auskennen mit dem Bereich.
Mir erschließt sich aber zum einen nicht, warum wird da dieses Firmenkonstrukt aufgezogen
mit irgendwie verschiedenen Verbindungen und dann geht das einmal nach Dubai
und dann geht es zu einer anderen Subfirma und dann immer hin und her.
Und eigentlich ist die Firma, die dahinter steckt, aber viel kleiner.
Und außerdem erklärt sich immer noch nicht, welcher Zahlungsanbieter steckt denn da überhaupt hinter.
Ist das ein komplett neu gegründeter?
Man weiß es ja nicht.
Werbung und AGB widersprechen sich jetzt schon.
Wenn das schon illegal ist, müsstest du wahrscheinlich 90% der Firmen die Werbung machen.
Also ich glaube, das dürfte nicht das Kriterium sein.
Letztendlich bist du ja frei, deine Verträge so zu gestalten, wie du willst.
Wenn das jemand unterschreibt, unter Meinung ist, er will das machen, ist das okay.
Bis jetzt ist ja noch nichts Großartiges passiert.
Also das mit dem Zahlungsanbieter finde ich allerdings sehr, sehr fragwürdig.
Das ist das allererste, warum ich neben den ganzen anderen Punkten das nie im Leben in Erwägung ziehen würde.
Die können ja da wirklich Wildcard einsetzen, was sie wollen.
Und vielleicht habe ich da den ausschlaggebenden Punkt gefunden, wer dahinter stecken könnte.
Ich nenne es extra im Konjunktiv.
Denn in Verbindung mit HiWiFi findet man wiederum eine übergeordnete Website mit dem Namen GigaConnect Group.
Alter, wie viele GigaConnect-Unternehmen gibt es denn da jetzt?
Das ist schon eine fünfte oder so.
Da geht es ehrlicherweise deutlich schwammiger zu, weil es da nicht um ein konkretes Produkt geht.
Aber ich zitiere mal einen Bereich.
Dies passiert mit tiefgreifenden methodischen Kenntnissen, fundierter Transformationserfahrung
und einem hohen Maß an technologischem Verständnis sowie tiefer Expertise in der Wertgenerierung ausstaut.
Aber das ist auch schon ein ziemlicher Bullshit-Satz, oder?
Also möglichst viele Worte und tolle Begriffe.
Fundierter Transformationserfahrung.
Ja, da stehen wahrscheinlich die CEOs und sonst was dieser Welt auf solche Wörter.
Ich finde das immer sehr viel heiße Luft.
Aber der Wertgenerierung aus Daten klingt natürlich schon ein bisschen fragwürdiger.
Das neue Gold des 21. Jahrhunderts gewinnen.
Gewinnen wir durch modernste künstliche Intelligenz eigene APIs.
Äh, okay.
Das ist auch so.
Einfach mal einen Technikbegriff reingeschrieben.
Ob es jetzt irgendwie Sinn macht oder nicht an der Stille.
Dies alles end-to-end aus einer.
Bla bla bla bla bla bla bla bla.
Anführungszeichen gesetzt auch auf der Webseite.
Das neue Gold des 21. Jahrhunderts gewinnen wir durch modernste künstliche Intelligenz eigene APIs.
Sehr shady alles.
Das alles end-to-end aus einer Hand über den ganzen Transformationsprozess.
Und da geht es dann offenbar wirklich um Daten von Kunden.
Denn das neue Gold des 21. Jahrhunderts spielt ganz klar darauf an,
dass unter anderem Facebook, Google und die ganzen anderen großen Unternehmen
sich eine goldene Nase damit verdienen,
dass sie halt wirklich sehr, sehr viel über ihre Kunden wissen
und das an die Werbewirtschaft verkaufen können.
Und wenn ich da so eins und eins zusammenzähle, wäre das zumindest meine Vermutung,
dass das auch irgendwo eine Rolle spielen wird.
Denn wenn ich die ganzen Sachen über die App abwickeln muss
oder gegebenenfalls über diesen Router,
dann werden natürlich auch relativ viele Daten erhoben,
die dann in irgendeiner Form monetarisiert werden können.
Und um die Zahlungsdienstleister anzusprechen, auf die ich hinauswollte,
auf dieser Website findet sich ebenfalls ein Logo von VR Payments.
Und VR sind tatsächlich die guten alten Volksbanken Raiffeisenbahnen.
Ah, die sind auch am Start.
Das ist ein Zahlungsdienstleister, mit dem zumindest diese Firma zusammenarbeitet
oder zusammengearbeitet hat.
Unter anderem sind die wohl auch irgendwie in Giro Pay involviert.
Und meine These wäre jetzt zumindest, dass dieser Zahlungsdienstleister,
der da im Hintergrund steckt, VR Payments sein könnte.
Erneut das Ganze im Konjunktiv. Es muss nicht zwingend sein.
Es kann auch jemand komplett anderes sein.
Aber wenn man diesen ganzen Strängen so folgt,
ist das die für mich logische Schlussfolgerung.
Und ihr merkt schon, das geht wirklich sehr, sehr ins Detail.
Und ich habe hier wirklich noch sehr, sehr viel ausgelassen.
Also man kann da sehr, sehr viel Zeit verbringen,
diesen ganzen Strängen zu folgen.
Ihr könnt das gerne auch zu Hause nachmachen.
Und das nicht verwagen müssen.
Und Andi Leach, denke ich auch. Es gibt genug, die das machen.
Und schaut da gerne, ob ihr vielleicht noch andere Verbindungen findet,
die möglicherweise noch irgendwie aussagekräftiger sind.
Mein persönliches Fazit an dieser Stelle,
es gibt dann doch ein paar Haken, denn es ist unter anderem ungeklärt ...
Es ist sehr shady alles auf jeden Fall.
Also wie dieses Monetarisierungsmodell letztlich konkret aussieht.
Dann finde ich zumindest dieses Konstrukt aus verschiedenen GmbHs
mit verschiedenen Inhabern und irgendwie Subfirmen über Dubai
zumindest mal etwas merkwürdig.
Und da habe ich auch unseren Chef gefragt, der sich mit sowas eher auskennt.
Der sagte auch, ja, das ist, wenn man sowas seriös aufziehen möchte,
zumindest mal ungewöhnlich.
Und der letzte Punkt, gewisse Aussagen in den AGB
widersprechen auch schlichtweg den Aussagen aus der Werbung.
Was für mich grundsätzlich schon mal ein No-Go ist.
Denn ich möchte bitte auch in der Werbung,
selbst wenn man da ein bisschen blumiger die Dinge formuliert,
nicht irgendwie komplett andere Dinge erzählt kriegen,
als dann letztlich im Kleingedruckten stehen.
Ich bin mal gespannt, was da rauskommt.
Ich bin mal gespannt, ob es jemals ein ...
Internetanschlüsse, also Glasfaser gelegt werden.
Haltet lieber erst mal die Füße still,
selbst wenn ihr auf den ersten Blick da nichts zu verlieren habt.
Es ist nicht wirklich durchschaubar.
Und ich würde da erst mal Abstand von nehmen, euch da einzutragen.
Wenn sich da neue Infos ergeben,
wir können mal Peter Wobbler eintragen oder so was
und gucken, was dann passiert.
Eine kurze Plädoyer halten an die Journalisten da draußen,
denn ich bin explizit keiner.
Warum man entschieden, der DB anscheinend,
weil der Gründer Connections zur Bahn hat.
Spitzweise Leute wie bei Kaiser Online
oder auch bei Golem oder bei Computerbase,
sich da mal ein bisschen näher hinzusetzen.
Dann auch mal natürlich bei Gigafiber offiziell nachzufragen
und die mit gewissen Konstellationen einfach zu konfrontieren.
Vielleicht haben die ja eine Erklärung dafür,
die ich jetzt einfach nicht nachvollziehen kann.
Da war jetzt innerhalb dieser Kürze der Zeit nicht die Möglichkeit zu.
Sonst hätte ich das natürlich auch gerne gemacht.
Aber ich wollte gerne vorm Wochenende noch mit einem Video dazu rausgehen,
um euch da einfach darauf hinzuweisen,
dass es da nach aktuellem Stand Unstimmigkeiten gibt
und ich da erstmal persönlich die Finger von lassen würde.
Ja, nachvollziehbar.
Das Werbevideo mit VPN ist...
Was passiert mit meinen Daten?
Okay.
Gigafiber...
Diese Innovationsmusik im Hintergrund, Alter.
Ich kann sie nicht mehr hören.
Das haben total viele.
...größten Wert auf Datenschutz.
So werden deine Daten auf deutschen Servern
nach DSGVO-Normen vertraulich verarbeitet.
Tatsächlich...
Ob Dubai sich da dran hält?
...funktioniert der Gigafiber-Router während seiner Nutzung wie ein VPN.
Du bist also sogar gegen jeden geschützt,
der unerlaubt an deine Daten will.
Das ergibt überhaupt gar keinen Sinn.
...ein besseres, sicheres, unabhängiges, resilientes Netz.
Zum Preis von 0 Euro.
Du hast mehr Fragen zum Datenschutz?
Dann check die FAQs in der App.
Alles, was du für dein gratis Internet tun musst, ist
App herunterladen, Daten eintippen und absenden.
...wirklich gar keinen Sinn.
Aber...
Was hat 100 MBit mit Glasfaser zu tun?
Das ist schlechter als viele DSL-Anschlüsse noch.
Wobei, nee.
Ist bei VDSL nicht sogar bei 100 MBit Schluss?
Nee, 250, gell?
Ich glaub, VDSL geht bis maximal 250.
Aber dann auch nur unter optimalsten Bedingungen.
Also, ich würde mir das sofort anschließen lassen.
Sobald's bei uns Glasfaser gibt. Instant.
Was stimmt, was schreibt Golem?
Viele Fragezeichen beim neuen Anbieter.
Oh, nee, das lese ich jetzt nicht drei Seiten.
Ein Gigafibersprecher versicherte Golem.
Klar, es werden dem Kunden in keinem Fall Kosten für die Erstellung geben.
Mal gucken, was da rauskommt.
Bin gespannt.
Extrem langes, aber gutes Video.
Das hab ich sogar schon offen, aber das will ich mir nicht angucken.
Eine Stunde 24, da wären wir heute nicht fertig.
Wenn ich in eine Stunde 24 Video gucke,
da brauch ich, so wie ich mich kenne, drei Stunden für.
So, was haben wir denn sonst noch hier?
Windows neuer Servicevertrag, totale Überwachung, Verhaltenskodex, Faktencheck.
Oh je, da werden die Fakten gecheckt.
Die checken wir erstmal später.
1,24, das ist zu lang.
Was ist das?
Mit und ohne Cloud versteckte Funktionen von Google und Apple Fotos.
Juckt mich jetzt nicht so.
Morpheus hat YouTubes neue Adblock-Strategie und was das bedeutet.
Das bedeutet, dass YouTube gucken mehr Abfuck wird.
Ohne.
Als Softwareentwickler.
Nicht so laut.
Super demotivierter Softwareentwickler.
Das bedeutet, dass wenn man nicht YouTube Premium hat, es noch mehr Abfuck wird zu gucken.
Es reicht ja nicht nur doppelte Anzeigen am Anfang mit Rollanzeigen und alles möglich.
Jetzt auch noch unskippable Anzeigen.
Aber das ist zu lang, das Video gucke ich jetzt nicht.
Der macht immer gute Videos.
Aber das ist mir echt zu lang.
Haben wir noch irgendwas Gutes?
Sonst gucke ich mir jetzt an.
Wie Linux insgeheim die Welt kontrolliert.
Das klingt schon ein bisschen reißerisch, oder?
Guck mal, ich kriege meine eigenen Videos empfohlen.
Muss ich anklicken?
Hallo Leute, hier ist der Max und heute will ich euch mal...
Viewtime.
Ich weiß nicht.
Das Beste ist, sich YouTube Premium zu holen, dann hat man das Problem nicht.
Und wenn euch YouTube Premium zu teuer ist, dann kauft euch YouTube Premium in Indien.
Jetzt.
Achso.
Warum gibt es...
Warum gibt es ein neues Gothic 1 Remake, oder was, oder wie, oder was?
Das gucken wir jetzt nicht komplett.
Das interessiert mich einfach nur.
Ende September gibt es den Rollenspielklassiker Gothic 1 auch auf der Switch.
Ach, auf der Switch.
Ja, das sollte sogar die Switch schaffen.
Willst du dir den Account sperren?
Wieso gibt es...
Werden da wirklich Accounts für gesperrt?
Okay.
Also ich habe ja einen privaten Account.
Da habe ich das schon eine Weile.
Wobei es gar nicht mein privater Account ist.
Mit aus Indien.
Okay, Max, genug Viewtime.
Microsofts neuer Servicevertrag erlaubt totale Überwachung aller Benutzer.
Also wenn ich die letzten Jahre über eins gelernt habe, ist...
Sobald irgendwie die Möglichkeit besteht, wird es auch zunehmend ausgenutzt und gemacht.
Und das wird hier relativ ähnlich sein.
Und zumindest besteht hier das Potential, dass das relativ ähnlich wird.
Ich meine, auch wenn es ein komplett anderes Beispiel ist,
und da hat es mit dem Microsoft-Vertrag nichts zu tun.
Eines der Beispiele, wo man das, denke ich, ganz gut sehen kann,
sobald die Möglichkeit da ist, sobald was...
Ja, sobald die Voraussetzungen da sind,
dass es dann auch benutzt wird für Sachen, die explizit angekündigt wurden,
dass sie nicht gemacht werden, ist...
Ihr erinnert euch vielleicht noch daran, als...
Von dem habe ich schon ein paar Videos geguckt.
Dutti, von dem Typ, äh, von, ähm...
Wie heißt der? Jorg? Jorgs?
Jorginson, ja.
Von dem habe ich auch schon ein paar Videos geguckt.
Ähm, was wollte ich jetzt sagen? Genau.
Also, ein Beispiel dafür ist...
Erinnert euch vielleicht noch daran,
wo man während Corona dazu angehalten war,
wenn man in ein Restaurant geht,
aufzuschreiben, so, Kontaktdaten,
dass man im Fall der Fälle, wenn da was ist,
dann kontaktiert werden kann.
War sinnvoll, und im Nachhinein fand ich das jetzt auch nicht so wild.
Aber, was man daran gesehen hat, ist...
Ein paar Wochen später, obwohl das, glaube ich,
ganz gut funktioniert,
ein paar Wochen später, obwohl das nur rein zweckgebunden verwendet werden sollte,
kam die bayerische Polizei um die Ecke und hat gesagt,
ja, ja dann, dann gebt uns doch mal die Daten,
wir wollen da jetzt auch Zugriff drauf haben.
Und daran sieht man, sobald die Möglichkeit besteht,
die Voraussetzung geschaffen ist,
dann wird das, dann dauert es meistens auch nicht lang,
bis das Maximale gemacht wird.
Das heißt, ich bin bei sowas immer skeptisch,
wenn sich irgendwelche Unternehmen,
oder es ist egal wer,
wenn sich irgendeiner hinstellt und sagt,
wir schaffen uns mal super weitreichende Rechte,
aber macht euch keine Sorgen,
wir benutzen das gar nicht.
Da bin ich immer skeptisch, ja.
Lass uns das doch mal schnell angucken, komm her.
Skippen wir mal drüber, 14 Minuten.
Keck Alu-Time.
Microsofts neuer Servicevertrag erlaubt total über...
Ah, okay, jetzt geht's schon wieder damit los.
Ja, wie gesagt, ich sehe das,
wahrscheinlich sieht er das überhaupt nicht so,
aber ich sehe das immer...
Was könnte schiefgehen?
Ich mach mir schnell einen Alu-Hut und bin gleich wieder da.
Oh, Keck Alu!
Excellent.
So, jetzt bin ich bereit.
Microsofts neuer Servicevertrag
erlaubt Totalüberwachung aller Nutzer.
Titelt aktuell sehr reißerisch die Webseite tankappe.info.
Ich habe sehr viele Kommentare und Mails dazu erhalten,
weswegen ich an dieser Stelle ein paar Details davon analysieren möchte.
Ganz viele Nutzer, mit denen ich diskutiert habe,
benutzen diesen Artikel als Quelle
und daher wollen wir auch über diesen Artikel reden.
Also?
Im Artikel ist die Rede von Machtmissbrauch.
Es wird suggeriert, Microsoft arbeite mit Gestapo-Methoden.
Und am Ende gibt es natürlich für all diese Probleme
eine einzige Lösung und die heißt Linux.
Ich hab mir den Artikel...
Ist sicherlich eine Lösung,
wenn man keinen Bock auf Windows hat
und die ganze Scheiße...
Was zum Teufel?
Moment, wenn man die Maustaste gedrückt hätte,
läuft das Video jetzt schneller.
Seit wann ist das denn?
What the fuck?
Aber Leute, Leute, Leute, Leute, Leute.
Nicht einfach nur Linux.
Ihr wisst es genau.
Welches Linux?
Ich will es jetzt hören, Chat.
By the way.
Arch-Linux.
Der Chat weiß schon Bescheid.
Arch-Linux, natürlich.
Wenn schon, richtig.
Geht auch vielleicht.
Arch-Linux muss es sein.
Wenn überhaupt, dann Arch-Linux.
By the way.
Ich komme hier nicht zum selben Schluss wie der Autor.
Das sage ich euch ganz ehrlich.
Einerseits auffällig bei diesem Artikel ist konkret,
wie wenig Beweise der Autor liefert
für seine ziemlich extremen Behauptungen.
Im gesamten Artikel,
worin Microsoft auf Basis des Servicevertrags vorgeworfen wird,
die totale Überwachung von Nutzern zu ermöglichen,
wird kein...
Ich muss euch ehrlich sagen,
ich kann euch nichts Stichhaltiges dazu sagen.
Ich habe das selbst nicht gelesen.
...ein einziges Mal auch nur ein einziges Wort,
geschweige denn ein Satz,
aus dem Microsoft-Servicevertrag zitiert.
Was denkt ihr, woran das liege?
Denn ein Satz...
Ja gut, mein...
Ja gut, okay.
Es ist nicht der Servicevertrag selbst.
Ja gut.
Vertrag...
Vertragliche Relevanz für den Nutzer nicht,
aber das interessiert doch eh keinen.
Also Microsoft...
Es ist ja nicht so,
als ist das jetzt was,
womit du dann zu Microsoft gehen könntest
und sagen,
guck mal,
so habe ich das aber nicht unterschrieben.
Theoretisch schon,
praktisch nicht.
...aus dem Microsoft-Servicevertrag zitiert.
Was denkt ihr, woran das liege?
Vergleichen wir also die aktuellen Vorwürfe
wirklich mal mit Microsoft-Servicevertrag.
Der Servicevertrag ist wahrscheinlich
deutlich schwammiger,
als das, was auf der Seite steht.
Aber schwammig ist gerade in solchen Fällen
meistens nicht gut.
Hier steht zum Beispiel,
Microsoft nimmt sich damit das Recht heraus,
uns von vorne bis hinten zu durchleuchten,
heißt es wortwörtlich.
Ja gut, das haben sie ja jetzt mehr oder weniger auch schon.
Und als Beweis liefert der Autor
das einzige Zitat vom gesamten Artikel mit
und das ist auch tatsächlich das einzige Zitat
von Microsoft und das lautet,
Wir verwenden Hashes
von bekannten illegalen und schädlichen Inhalten.
Wir verwenden auch unsere eigene Technologie
und Klassifikatoren,
um schädliche Inhalte zu finden,
die über unsere Dienste verbreitet werden.
Daraus folgert der Autor folgendes.
Also was ich daraus folgern würde ist,
dass im Zweifelsfall Microsoft die Sachen,
die auf meinem PC sind,
scannt nach illegalen,
wie auch immer das bei Microsoft so definiert ist,
oder nach schädlichen und illegalen Inhalten.
Das würde ich da rein interpretieren.
Ich weiß nicht, wie ihr das seht, Chad.
Ich würde rein interpretieren,
Microsoft kann meinen kompletten PC scannen,
ob sie irgendwas finden, was ihnen nicht passt.
Das heißt, dass alle Inhalte auf unserer Festplatte
und in der Cloud 24-7 automatisch
auf bestimmte Keywords hin untersucht werden.
Ja, das klingt jetzt sehr ultimativ,
wie er das geschrieben hat,
aber die Interpretation dazu besteht ja,
denke ich, durchaus.
Es klingt scary, aber es ist faktisch,
ich kann es nicht anders sagen,
es ist einfach falsch.
Daher sage ich es hier klipp und klar,
das Thema hat nichts mit Windows zu tun,
sondern ausschließlich mit Microsofts Diensten.
Es steht fast wortwörtlich im ersten Satz
des Servicevertrags, wenn man hier klickt,
dass Windows hier gar nicht dazugehört.
Niemand gleicht also eure privaten Fotos
auf eurer Festplatte ab.
Es geht da nicht um eure Festplatte.
Niemand greift auf eure Fotos zu
und vergleicht sie.
Selbst der OneDrive-Vergleich erfolgt
technisch gesehen nicht auf Keywords
und auch nicht visuell.
Wie das jetzt letztendlich gemacht wird
und wie es jetzt gerade ausgelegt wird,
ist ja nicht unbedingt gleich dem,
was der Vertrag eigentlich hergeben würde, oder?
Ich meine, ich kann auch sagen,
ich räume mir das Recht ein,
jenen zu bannen bei mir im Chat
und ich banne vielleicht nur fünf Leute
und nicht alle.
Das heißt aber nicht,
dass ich morgen nicht alle banne,
so übertrieben gesagt jetzt.
Sondern basierend auf mathematischen Formeln.
Der Autor erwähnt zwar in diesem Artikel
Windows nicht explizit,
aber er spricht von eurer Festplatte
und daraus wird relativ schnell klar,
was der Autor damit erreichen will.
Ich finde das, Chat, wir müssen das jetzt,
seht das mal nicht so negativ jetzt.
Ich finde das sogar gut,
dass der ein Video dazu macht
und sich den Vertrag angeguckt hat.
Ich sehe da nichts Verwerfliches dran.
Bei mir ist es halt immer nur so,
ich denke, sobald die Möglichkeiten geschaffen sind,
muss man davon ausgehen,
dass sie früher oder später auch benutzt werden.
Linux versus OneDrive,
sondern Linux versus Windows.
Äpfel und Birnen, wie man so schön sagt.
Aber jetzt konkret.
Es ist auch die Frage,
PlayStation oder Xbox?
Was heißt Microsoft verwendet Hashes
von illegalen Inhalten
und gleicht diese mit jenen Daten ab?
Das stand ja nicht nur verwendet,
das stand als Erklärung da.
Im eigentlichen Vertrag stand doch,
Moment, wir merken uns,
wir sind bei 3.24.
Im eigentlichen Vertrag stand doch,
Wortwörtlich im ersten Satz des Servicevertrags,
wenn man hier klickt,
dass Windows,
äh, bin ich jetzt blöd verstanden, hier.
Darüber hinaus setzen wir unsere eigene Technologie
und Klassifiziere ein,
um schädliche Inhalte zu finden,
die über unsere Dienste verbreitet werden.
Ich meine,
ihre Dienste können auch so Dinger sein wie,
was weiß ich,
Windows Defender oder sowas.
Oder spätestens,
wenn einer irgendwelche VMs in der Cloud benutzt,
oder was auch immer.
Das ist, das ist,
das ist mega schwammig.
Das kann auch im Zweifelsfall wirklich alles sein.
Also ich sehe da schon,
also ich sehe es vielleicht nicht so,
so, so,
ja, das ist hundertprozentig so,
wie der eine Artikel,
aber ich finde schon,
dass man das durchaus da rein interpretieren kann.
Und wenn es nicht dein PC ist,
der durchsucht werden kann nach schädlichen Inhalten,
dann ist es auf jeden Fall die Sache,
die du in irgendeinem Cloud-Laufwerk
oder in irgendeinem Office oder sonst wo liegen hast.
Und dass das so ist,
kam ja auch letztens erst raus,
weil,
ihr erinnert euch noch vielleicht daran,
Mails, die über Outlook verschickt werden,
mit verschlüsselten ZIP-Archiven im Anhang,
werden versucht von Microsoft zu analysieren
und zu entschlüsseln.
Das kam, das gab es letztens erst,
größere Berichterstattung drüber.
Microsoft verwendet,
ja,
weiß nicht wie groß,
ein Wörterbuch mit Standard-Passwörtern
und versucht,
angehängte ZIP-Archive zu entschlüsseln.
Die an der Mail dranhängen.
Und, also,
wie gesagt,
ich denke halt immer nur,
sobald die Möglichkeiten da sind,
die eingeräumt sind,
dann werden die früher oder später auch benutzt.
Ja, und ich meine,
guck mal,
spätestens die Windows-Suche,
wenn du hier eingibst,
keckel, ja?
Dann findet man was auch immer alles.
Jetzt benutzt du einen Microsoft-Service
an der Stelle schon.
Also das ist alles sehr, sehr vage, ne?
...meiner OneDrive-Festplatte gespeichert sind.
Was ich auf Microsofts Diensten speichere,
wie wird das denn mit irgendwelchen Inhalten,
illegalen Inhalten,
ähm,
verglichen?
Der Autor spricht konkret von Keywords,
aber er könnte ferner von der Wahrheit nicht sein.
Der Satz beschreibt konkret,
wie Microsoft nach illegalen Inhalten
in OneDrive und seinen anderen Online-Diensten filtert.
Nochmal,
das hat nix mit eurer Festplatte zu tun
und auch nix mit euren Dateien auf eurem Windows-PC.
Hier wird nur die Basis der Technologie erklärt,
die übrigens nicht eure Fotos scannt oder durchsucht.
Diese Technologie benutzt sogar Google bei seinen Diensten
und auch Facebook benutzt...
Da kann man sich jetzt drüber streiten, ne?
Ob das schon ein Durchsuchen ist oder nicht.
Letztendlich,
wenn man mal wirklich vom einfachsten Fall ausgeht, ja?
Ähm,
Bilder werden in,
wie,
wie auch immer,
gehashed,
teilweise komplett,
wie dem auch sei,
und dann abgeglichen mit Hashes
von Bildern,
die,
sag mal,
irgendwelche illegalen,
bekannt,
du musst ja oft,
du musst ja quasi bekannte,
illegale Bilder nehmen
und die hashen und dann abgleichen.
So,
das Ding ist,
da hab ich vor ner ganzen Weile auch mal was drüber gelesen,
als Apple das angekündigt hat,
in ihrer Cloud zu scannen,
einfach Dateihashes
wird's bei Bildern
nicht tun.
Das müssen schon Verfahren sein,
um
gewisse,
gewisser,
wie soll man sagen,
ein bisschen,
ein bisschen breitflächiger,
als auf wirklich Bit-Ebene,
weil wir haben es uns letztens erst zusammen angeguckt,
änderst du ein Bit in einer Datei,
kommt ein komplett unterschiedlicher Hash raus.
So,
und das willst du ja gerade nicht,
ja?
Du komprimierst das Bild,
es ist ein anderer Hash am Ende, ja?
Du, also,
du Screenshottest das Bild von der Webseite,
es hat ein bisschen andere Formate,
ein neuer Hash.
Und das heißt gerade beim,
beim Thema Inhaltserkennung
brauchst du
eine gewisse, ja,
wie soll man das nennen?
Also kein bitweise Hash,
sondern etwas, was ein bisschen breiter,
breiter gefächert ist,
also wo du Inhalte
kategorisieren kannst,
nicht rein anhand
zu eins der Bits.
Und da können sich natürlich schon
die ein oder anderen
Fehler,
Fehlerkennungen einschleichen, ja?
Die ein oder anderen Fehler einschleichen, ja?
Also,
und dann ist auch das andere wieder,
jetzt überlegt euch mal,
irgendjemand hat ein Bild
von seinen Kindern
im Pool.
So,
die Kinder sind klein, die Kinder sind nackig,
hat ein Bild von seinen Kindern im Pool gemacht.
Also, die Chance, dass das
auf irgendwelche
Kinderporno-Referenz
Dinger matcht,
ist wahrscheinlich
gar nicht mal so gering.
Und das sind halt so Dinger, wo man sich dann
denkt, tja, wie geht
das dann weiter?
So, guck mal das Video mal.
Und sie wurde tatsächlich von Microsoft
selbst entwickelt und
von Strafverfolgungsbehörden kostenfrei
bereitgestellt. Hier ist nur eine kurze Erklärung
dieser Technologie, die sich übrigens
Fotodna nennt und die eigentlich mathematische
Formeln benutzt, um die Bilder
miteinander zu vergleichen. Siehste, siehste,
sind wir schon beim Thema, es sind keine
1 zu 1 Bit-Hashes, deswegen das
funktioniert bei Bildern ja auch nicht.
3% Fehlerquote ist enorm.
Also, ganz ehrlich,
bei 3% Fehlerquote,
wenn ich in den Aufzug steigen
müsste, und die sagen,
bei 3% der Fällen stürzt der Aufzug ab,
ich würde nicht reinsteigen.
3%
ist ganz schön viel.
Hier ist eine Erklärung. Fotodna
wurde in Zusammenarbeit mit dem National Center
for Missing and Exploited Children entwickelt
und berechnet einen mathematischen Hash
auf der Grundlage eines vorhandenen
Bildes, das Kinderpornografie
enthält. Der Hash muss
keine identifizierenden Informationen
enthalten und das Originalfoto muss
nicht an die Strafverfolgungsbehörden weitergegeben
werden. Fotodna ist keine
Gesichtserkennungssoftware
und kann nicht zur Identifizierung
einer Person oder eines Objekts
in einem Bild
verwendet werden.
Ja, aber da sind wir schon mal weit weg
von, das ist irgendwelche reine
reine Bitweise
Hashes, sondern du kannst
sehr wohl damit auf gewisse
Inhalte von den Sachen, die du dort
in der Cloud gespeichert hast, schließen.
Das Bild wird also
gab es sogar einen Artikel zu?
Ja, automatisierte
Scans, Microsoft spendet Kundenunterkünfte
nicht für immer aus.
Das ist halt,
was ich am Anfang meinte,
sobald du die Möglichkeit dafür
geschaffen hast,
wird das auch genutzt
irgendwann früher oder später.
Also abstrahiert, es wird in einen mathematischen
Hash konvertiert und dann werden
Dateien, die ihr auf eurem OneDrive habt,
auf Basis ihrer Hashes mit
einer Datenbank vermisster Kinder oder
Opfer sexuellen Missbrauchs verglichen.
Hier ist z.B. so ein Hash von einem Bild
und wie das auf dem OneDrive passiert,
dieses und Millionen
weiterer verstörender Bilder
wird mit den Hashes unserer Bilder
auf OneDrive abgeglichen.
Bei einem Treffer wird der Hash des Bildes
an das National Center for Missing and Exploited Children
geschickt zur weiteren Prüfung,
woraufhin die dann die Behörden
verständigen, wenn sich der Verdacht
erhärtet. Es werden also nicht eure
Bilder
und dann hat dann irgendeine Polizei vor der Tür
stehen, weil man ein Bild von seinen
Kindern im Pool gemacht hat.
analysiert und visuell verglichen,
sondern nur Hashes. Damit
eine Keyword basierte Analyse
stattfinden kann, müsste man
erstmal die Objekte auf den Bildern erkennen.
Z.B. Hund, Katze
oder Karotte und dies
dann eben mit einer Datenbank von rechtswidrigen
Bildern abgleichen.
Das braucht aber extrem
viel Rechenleistung, ist wesentlich
unpräziser als das mathematisch basierte
Fotodna-Modell und deswegen sind
auch eure Privatfotos im Regelfall
nicht problematisch, denn
Nein! Das hat er doch gerade
erklärt!
Es geht hier nicht um bitweise einzelne
Dinge. Es geht gerade da drum
Bilder von Kindern zu erkennen, die unter
anderem vermisst sind.
Also da geht es ja gerade nicht drum
bitweise die einzelnen
Fotos miteinander zu
vergleichen. Ja, das ist die nächste
Frage.
Nachdem die das Originalbild nicht haben,
nachdem die das Originalbild
sich nicht angucken können, ich hab keine Ahnung
wie das dann läuft, ob dann irgendjemand
die Polizei vor der Tür stehen hat.
Naja, also, wenn das
abgeglichen wird mit den Bildern von vermissten
Kindern, muss ja zumindest
in irgendeiner Art und Weise
was erkannt werden,
was sagt, ja das könnte das Kind,
das könnte das Gesicht von dem
vermissten Kind sein oder nicht. Wie genau
das funktioniert, wissen wir nicht.
Das kann auch sein, dass du einen, keine Ahnung,
den Strand fotografierst
und das zufälligerweise ähnlich
genug ist zu dem Bild von irgendeinem
vermissten Kind.
Also, wie gesagt, wenn
das stimmt mit den 3%
Fehlerquote, dann ist es enorm viel.
Nichtsdestotrotz ist es eigentlich vollkommen
egal.
Es passiert das,
was ja angeblich laut dem Video nicht passiert,
dass deine Bilder nicht,
ups, war geil,
abgeglichen werden.
Das ist eine bescheuerte Erklärung,
was die dafür benutzen.
Das ist im Endeffekt irgendeine
Erkennungsmöglichkeit,
wo es nicht darauf ankommt, dass du die Bilder
bitweise miteinander vergleichst,
sondern dass es eben
kein 1 zu 1 bitweise
vergleichen ist, sondern ein
ja,
als Fragmente
vergleichen, in irgendeiner Art und Weise.
Ich hab keine Ahnung, wie es funktioniert
und was, und ich weiß auch gar nicht, ob das überhaupt
öffentlich bekannt ist.
Es ist zumindest nicht
bitweise.
Ist das so?
Da hab ich meine Zweifel.
Ich mein,
wenn du Fragmente
erkennen kannst, in irgendeiner Art und Weise,
wenn du zum Beispiel darauf Rückschlüsse ziehen kannst,
okay, auf dem Bild könnte
eines der vermissten Kinder
drauf sein.
Natürlich kann das in die Hose gehen
und Mist detekten.
Und selbst wenn wir bei 0,1%
sind,
selbst wenn es wirklich,
wirklich viel, viel geringer wäre,
selbst wenn man bei 0,1% ist,
guckt mal, wie viele Millionen
Sachen da verglichen werden.
Ja, und sicherlich werden
dann bei der genaueren Überprüfung
von denen die erkannt werden,
die falsch sind, auch noch einige rausfliegen.
Aber früher oder später
haben Leute
Polizei vor der Tür stehen, die nix
damit zu tun haben.
Und selbst bei Fingerabdrücken,
Leute, ihr dürft nicht vergessen,
Fingerabdrücke
wurden und werden ja immer noch
als ziemlich gutes, ja so
Unique
Identifikationsmittel
benutzt.
Und selbst Fingerabdrücke haben
gar nicht so, so selten
Kollisionen.
Zwar sehr selten, aber es kommt durchaus vor.
Es gibt,
ich hab da letztens erst was drüber gelesen,
ich weiß nicht, ob man das Kollisionen überhaupt
nennt, ja, oder
Fingerabdrücke,
dass Leute,
ja,
dass Leute teilweise so,
also Leute, die nicht miteinander verwandt sind,
so ähnliche Fingerabdrücke
haben können, dass
die beispielsweise den Finger
scannen können an einem,
ja, Eingang zu einem Rechenzentrum
oder so und der akzeptiert werden würde.
Weil das Ding ist halt,
suchst du jemand,
der Fingerabdrücke hat,
also glücklicherweise ist es nicht ganz so schlimm
in so Verdachtsfällen,
weil suchst du jemand,
der exakt zu diesem Fingerabdruck
passt, ist es natürlich enorm schwierig,
einen zu finden, suchst du einfach nur zwei
Leute, die einen
ähnlich genugen Fingerabdruck haben, wirst du auf jeden Fall
genug finden.
Ja, also so Fingerabdruckkollisionen
kommen öfters vor, als man denkt.
Nicht, dass Force Positives
ausgeschlossen sind und, dass
Leute bereits wegen eines Fehlers dieses Systems
ihre Accounts verloren haben, das stimmt.
Ja. Aber ich wollte hier nur
klarstellen, wie genau dieser Abgleich funktioniert
und er bezieht sich tatsächlich
nur darauf, was ihr auf OneDrive und Outlook
oder Skype rumsendet und eben nicht,
was auf eurer Windows
Festplatte drauf ist. Es werden hier
noch ein paar andere Punkte. Mag jetzt so sein,
sollte
der Vertrag das ermöglichen
oder sollte das, vielleicht nicht jetzt schon,
man weiß ja nie, wird das
früher oder später auch gemacht.
Darunter wird die neue
Meldefunktion als Einladung
zur Denunzierung bezeichnet.
Er hat übrigens ein nice T-Shirt.
Der Autor suggeriert hier, man könnte
unliebsame Zeitgenossen, also eure
Feinde, sozusagen
durch Meldung ihres Accounts
Ärger bereiten. Das klingt doch sehr
nach Gestapo, findet ihr nicht?
Was hier konkret gemeint
sein dürfte, ist sehr wahrscheinlich
der Punkt 4 Absatz B2
der Richtlinie. Ja, das finde ich im Originalartikel dann
aber auch ein bisschen schwammig. Ich meine,
wenn du sowas behauptest,
solltest du ja mal zumindest die Stelle von diesem
Servicevertrag verlinken können
oder zitieren können, der dich
zu dieser Annahme bringt.
Richtlinien, ich sage wahrscheinlich,
denn im Artikel wird keine einzige
dieser Richtlinien konkret genannt.
Ja, na gut, willkommen im Club.
Solche Richtlinien werden ja überall,
guckt euch Twitch an oder sonstige Plattformen,
die sind ja überall immer super schwammig.
Lesen wir das erstmal gemeinsam.
Hier steht, sie können bedenkliche Inhalte
oder Verhaltensweisen, die gegen unseren
Verhaltenskodex verstoßen,
hier melden.
Microsoft hat also jetzt eine
Meldefunktion, sodass ihr einen Account
bei Microsoft melden könnt,
wenn dieser euch Spam, Pornografie
einer bestimmten kriminellen Art
oder andere laut Geschäftsbedingungen
inkorrekte Inhalte per Mail
schickt oder per Skype zum Beispiel
oder euch einen Freigabelink auf
Das gibt, diese Meldefunktion gibt es
bei, gibt es ja bei nahezu jeder
Plattform und bei nahezu jeder Plattform
wurde die auch schon missbraucht.
Weil, das gucken sich ja erstmal
gar keine Leute an, wenn genug
Meldungen, zum Beispiel auf YouTube,
hat man es ja schon öfters gesehen, dass Videos
gelöscht werden, teilweise Accounts suspendiert
werden, weil einfach nur in genug,
in kurz genugem Abstand
genug Leute was reported haben.
Ja, oftmals wird das
im Nachhinein wieder aufgehoben,
aber oftmals, und das hat man auch
gerade im Bereich, tja so
Security-Videos schon gesehen,
hat der Typ, der sich das auf YouTube anguckt
gar keinen Plan von dem, was er sich
anguckt und sagt, oh ja,
natürlich, das ist ein Hacking-Video,
böser Inhalt.
Es wurde auf nahezu
jeder Plattform schon missbraucht, das Meldesystem.
Trotzdem, denke ich, ist es wichtig,
dass es ein Meldesystem gibt.
Da die Balance zu finden ist
sehr kostenintensiv, wahrscheinlich
für den Anbieter.
Unfassbar, oder?
Wo kommen wir denn dahin,
wenn man jetzt auch online Leute
melden kann? Was andere
Dienste wie Facebook, Reddit und Dropbox
und Google haben ebenfalls Geschäftsbedingungen
und dort kann man auch Leute
wegen Verstößen melden?
Also, dass es die Funktion gibt,
finde ich nicht schlimm, aber dass die Funktion
nicht gebraucht werden kann, hat man oft genug gesehen.
Echt nur Twitter noch geblieben
als einziger freier Ort?
Nee, Twitter hat das auch. Auf Twitter kriegst
du aber witzigerweise immer so eine Meldung
danach, so
wir wurden darauf hingewiesen,
dass es hier illegale Inhalte sind, eine Prüfung hat
ergeben, die Inhalte sind nicht illegal.
Und noch ein Punkt,
der in diesem Artikel thematisiert wird,
betrifft den neuen Verhaltenskodex
oder die Verhaltensregeln, die Microsoft
definiert. Diese wurden
implementiert, weil Microsoft erst kürzlich
künstliche Intelligenz zu seinen Diensten
hinzugefügt hat. Ich weiß jetzt schon, was ich
im neuen Windows Update nicht benutzen werde.
Da hat man für diese Dienste
eben ein paar Verhaltensregeln
definiert. Wer nur den ersten Punkt
liest, wobei ich bezweifle, dass der Autor
auch das überhaupt gemacht hat,
könnte diese als vage erachten,
aber es ist hier doch recht klar
definiert, was Microsoft als
unrechtmäßige Handlungen ansieht.
Es sind hauptsächlich Sachen,
womit ihr sehr wahrscheinlich gegen
geltendes deutsches Recht verstoßen würdet.
Aber wer schert sich schon um das
Gesetz? Ich lasse mir keinen
Verhaltenskodex vorschreiben,
schreibt der Autor auf seiner Seite.
Der geht auch immer aus Prinzip bei Rot über die Ampel.
Kurz zusammengefasst, damit ich das
jetzt nicht alles vorlesen muss, aber wir
werden die jeweiligen Absätze von den
richtigen... Also solche
Verhaltenssachen gibt's ja auf jeder Seite,
gibt's auf Twitch ja auch.
Bei Twitch ist eher das Problem,
dass es immer mal so, mal so
alles ausgelegt wird.
Ja, dass es jetzt sowas gibt,
das groß juckt, weiß nicht.
...Richtlinien im Video
herzeigen und zitieren und ihr werdet sie
auch unten in der Videobeschreibung verlinkt finden.
Man soll
laut dem neuen Verhaltenskodex
keine Inhalte teilen oder generieren,
die dazu gedacht sind, Kindern zu schaden.
Man darf keinen Spam versenden,
keine betrügerischen Handlungen durchführen
und Microsoft verbietet auch, seine künstliche
Intelligenz zu Reverse-Engineeren oder
zu Jailbreaken, um diese
beispielsweise zur Erstellung von Malware
zu kriegen. Microsoft hat
gewisse Barrieren implementiert, was
Chat-GPT und deren Bildgeneratoren
und so weiter können,
dürfen und was eben nicht.
Zum Beispiel soll es keine
Viren herstellen oder Captchas lösen,
obwohl es das easy peasy
könnte. Microsoft sagt,
man wird Nutzer davon ausschließen,
von seinen Diensten, die aktiv
sind, versuchen, diese Dienste zu manipulieren
oder für potenziell unlautere
oder gefährliche Zwecke zu benutzen.
Der einzige Kritikpunkt, den ich
jetzt konkret habe,
ist Punkt 3, Absatz 8
des Servicevertrags.
Das lese ich euch ganz kurz vor.
Da steht, verletzen sie nicht
die Rechte anderer, zum Beispiel durch unbefugtes
Teilen von urheberrechtlich geschützter Musik
oder anderen urheberrechtlich geschützten
Materialien und so weiter.
Das ist
meiner Meinung nach ein Problem.
Microsoft macht nämlich euch
dafür verantwortlich, wenn ihr deren
Bildgenerator nutzt und dieser ein Foto
ausschüttet. Naja, das macht Microsoft,
dass sie keine Horde von Anwälten vor der Tür stehen
haben. Praktisch passieren wird einem trotzdem nichts.
Das eine Urheberrechtsverletzung darstellt.
Also wenn ihr dieses Bild
dann kommerziell verwendet, zum Beispiel auf der
Facebookseite eurer Pizzeria.
Das Problem ist, ihr könnt als Nutzer
eigentlich gar nicht wissen, mit welchem
Material das AI-Modell
produziert wurde. Und zu beweisen, ob die
AI das Werk einer anderen Person
tatsächlich genutzt hat, ist
schwierig für den Nutzer, wenn nicht
sogar ganz unmöglich.
Aber das ist schon sehr weit weg von
den Vorwürfen, die wir in diesem Artikel
formuliert haben.
Also ich denke mal, der Artikel ist
sehr, sagen wir so,
in die eine Richtung übertrieben.
Ich finde, das Video ist vielleicht
auch ein bisschen, schwingt dann noch ein bisschen
zu sehr in die andere Richtung aus.
Man kann es einfach realistisch sehen.
Sobald Möglichkeiten da sind,
sobald Möglichkeiten geschaffen sind, was zu machen,
früher oder später wird es auch gemacht.
...sei aber trotzdem hier dazu erwähnt.
Also, sind Microsofts neue
Nutzungsbedingungen dazu gemacht,
um die Totalüberwachung aller Nutzer zu ermöglichen?
Nein.
Sind sie nicht?
Die Frage ist nicht,
wurden sie dazu mit der Absicht gemacht,
sondern geben sie es her?
...gewissen Punkten vage oder gar problematisch?
Für gewisse Nutzer ja.
Wer die Bing-AI benutzen will,
um Malware zu programmieren oder
illegale Inhalte zu generieren, die
mit Kindern zu tun haben,
der könnte seinen Microsoft-Account relativ schnell
verlieren. Wer seine Outlook-Email
benutzt, um anderen Nutzern
Spam zu schicken, der könnte
seinen Microsoft-Account verlieren.
Und wer glaubt, er könnte den Bing-Bildgenerator
benutzen, um ein Foto von Jessica
Alba zu kreieren, wie sie in den leckeren
Kebab eures Dönerladens
beißt und diesen dann als
Facebook-Post zu verwenden, der
könnte Post bekommen von ihren Anwälten
und Microsoft wird euch nicht
zu Hilfe eilen. Das
steht so in den AGBs.
Ich stimme dem übrigens zu,
dass wir uns von den Anbietern unserer
Dienste nicht alles gefallen lassen sollten.
Kritik ist insbesondere angebracht,
wenn Kinderschutz als Vorwand benutzt wird.
Wer Spam über sein Bing-Account schickt,
die Leute, denen der Account
übernommen wurde von irgendwelchen anderen
Leuten. Also ich denke nicht, dass jemand absichtlich
Spam wissentlich über sein
Bing-Account verschickt, aber es kommt
jetzt in der Vergangenheit auch, also ich weiß nicht,
ob ihr das auch schon mal hattet, dass ihr von
Leuten oder von Absenderadressen, die ihr
eigentlich kennt,
schon mal Spam bekommen habt.
Das natürlich besonders tückig ist,
je nachdem, wie gut der ist, weil du Leute
kennst und dann kommt meistens im Nachhinein raus,
ja, der Account, den hat er einfach jahrelang nicht
benutzt und irgendwie
hat sich einer Zugang zum Account verschafft
und verschickt damit jetzt Spam.
Daten durchsuchbar zu machen und diese
beispielsweise für Werbezwecke dann zu
verwenden. Oder wenn Jugendschutz ein
Vorwand ist für strategische Überlegungen,
wie das zum Beispiel bei Sony und
dem Minecraft-Crossplay der Fall war.
Aber die Wahrheit ist,
bei der News rund um die
aktuellen Nutzungsbedingungen von
Microsofts Diensten, da wird viel
übertrieben. Mal ganz einfach abgesehen,
die Leute, die weiter Windows Office
365, Teams und Microsoft
Offices verwenden, wollen
schräg schräg müssen, kommen da eh nicht drum herum.
Eine Verbindung mit Windows hergestellt,
wo sie sie gar nicht gibt
und es werden bewusst
Tatsachen verstellt oder aus dem Kontext
gerissen. Ah, der Originalartikel
erscheint mir auch etwas übertrieben.
Kann man so machen,
ist aber nicht wirklich großartige
journalistische Praxis und es schadet
ehrlich gesagt der guten Sache mehr,
als es ihr nutzt. Für alles, was ich in diesem Video
sage, findet ihr unten die Links in der
Beschreibung aufgeführt und wir haben natürlich auch
einen Artikel geschrieben, der etwas näher
auf das Thema eingeht, damit das
hier im Video nicht zu lange wird.
Oder glaubt ihr, ich hab Spaß daran
Serviceverträge und AGBs zu lesen?
Es liegt mir hier außerdem fern,
den Verteidiger von Microsoft zu spielen
und wer behauptet, ich sei ein bezahlter
Microsoft-Chill, der soll doch mal
mein MacBook Pro Review gucken oder den
Servicevertrag einfach selbst lesen.
Ich hab objektiv alle Fakten
auf den Tisch gelegt und es ist alles
unten mit Links zu den Quellen
belegt, wie Armin sie ausübt.
Ich spreche in diesem Video einige...
Wie gesagt, vielleicht gerade
im ersten Teil ein bisschen zu
pro das Ganze oder vielleicht ein bisschen
zu lasch das ausgelegt, aber
bei manchen Sachen gebe ich ihm ja auch recht.
Also manche sind im Originalartikel
etwas sehr weit
an den Hahn herbeigezogen.
...reale Probleme dieses neuen
Servicevertrags an und ich decke Probleme,
aber auch Mythen rund um Windows
schon seit mehr als 10 Jahren hier auf
WindowsArea.de auf.
Es gibt Probleme und die Sache
mit den Accountsperrungen ist
tatsächlich ein wirklich ernsthaftes Thema,
das ich schon seit Jahren aktiv recherchiere
und womit ich mich noch näher befassen werde
in Zukunft, wenn ich...
Wer mir dabei
helfen möchte und sein Microsoft-Account
gesperrt bekommen hat, der kann gerne
über den Link in der Videobeschreibung bei
der Recherche helfen.
Accountsperrungen sind in der heutigen Zeit
ein enormes Problem, vor allem,
weil wir für viele Dinge
unseres digitalen Lebens auf einen Anbieter
setzen, wo wir dann all unsere Fotos,
Spiele, Filme usw. gespeichert haben.
Ich bin wahrscheinlich
in ganz vielen Sachen einer Meinung mit dem
Autor hier, aber es hilft
der Sache nicht, wenn man nicht objektiv
mit dem Thema umgeht und falsche
Vorwürfe formuliert. Das ist immer schwierig.
Ich meine,
die wenigsten Leute sind bei egal welchem
Thema also immer 100% objektiv.
Ein bisschen spielt ja immer noch mit rein,
was du selbst so im Kopf hast.
Womit man im Endeffekt nur Nutzer auffetzt.
Da muss man sich schon echt Mühe geben.
Unternehmen, aber
diese Kunden dann nicht wirklich
objektive Argumente mitgibt, sondern
hauptsächlich Polemik. Das will
ich hier verhindern und ich wünsche mir daher
eine faktenbasierte Diskussion, wie wir
auch das bei anderen Themen hier
praktizieren und wir
wollen hier Microsoft tatsächlich
faktenbasiert analysieren auf diesem Channel.
So, das
war's dann auch schon von mir und von diesem
Video über Microsoft. Das fällt manchen Leuten
allgemein sehr schwer.
Wie viele YouTube Tabs?
Wieso so viele sind das doch gar nicht? Guck mal, ich hab hier noch
ein paar mehr. Aber hier hab ich grad
nicht so viele.
Ich krieg langsam richtig Hunger,
Leute. Warum? Ach, weil Zeitumstellung.
Weil jetzt
eigentlich schon
12.30 Uhr ist, kann das sein?
12.13 Uhr, kann das sein?
War es gestern 12.30 Uhr?
Ich kann mir das immer nicht merken mit Zeitumstellung
in welche Richtung.
Oder ist es erst heute Nacht? Wann ist denn das?
Oder war das, war das
schon? Ne, das...
Ach, das ist erst!
Ne, ne, ne, ne, das war
jetzt, das war jetzt. Es war auf der Nacht von
Samstag auf Sonntag.
Das ist auch so Pepega-Kram.
Erinnert ihr euch noch dran,
dass vor 4, 5 Jahren oder so,
dass mal so eine Umfrage gab,
ob die
Zeitumstellung nicht abgeschafft werden soll.
Und ein Großteil der Bevölkerung hat gesagt,
ja, weg mit dem Scheiß. Und danach
hat man sich einfach gedacht, okay, wir ignorieren das
jetzt. Wir haben mal eine Umfrage gemacht, aber wir ignorieren
das jetzt. Wir machen nix.
Guck mal mal, EU-Zeitumstellung.
Was es dazu Neues gibt.
2018 war das sogar schon,
ne? Die können sich noch
nicht einigen. Okay, EU-Sachen
in einer Nussschale, quasi.
Das ist doch gefühlt immer so.
Ja, gar nicht, oder?
Der
NTP-Server hat doch damit gar nix zu tun.
Ist es nicht so, dass dein Client sagt,
was er, also, dass die
NTP-Zeit von einem
Client dann quasi umgerechnet wird in
lokale
Zeit? Der NTP-Server hat doch, glaube ich,
mit der Zeitzone und so gar nix groß zu tun.
Oder? Ich hab mich damit nie
so im Detail beschäftigt.
Also musst du einfach, also musst du
einfach gar nichts machen an deinem NTP-Server.
By the way,
wie hast du den gemacht? Ich hab
auch mal just for fun einen ESP32
NTP-Server gebaut.
Mit nem GPS-Empfänger.
GPS-Zeit geholt
und dann, aber ich hab das nie benutzt.
War einfach nur just for fun, um zu gucken, wie es funktioniert.
Ach, per Internet.
Das ist ja easy.
Dann brauchst du auch kein
ESP32 dafür.
So, haben wir noch irgendwas, was wir uns angucken können?
Was ist das?
Und damit herzlich willkommen...
Alter, was? Wieso meine Fachinformatik
Abschlussprüfung eine Katastrophe war?
22 Minuten, was kann ich mir jetzt denn angucken? Ich hab Hunger.
Hunger AF hab ich.
Ich würd mir tatsächlich mal
das hier angucken am Anfang.
Zumindest. YouTubes neue Adblock
Strategie und was das bedeutet.
Gucken, was Morpheus dazu sagt. Mal gespannt.
YouTube hat neue
Adblock-Blocker. Mittlerweile könnt ihr
über drei YouTube-Videos mit Adblocker
schauen und anschließend geht nichts mehr.
Und ja, damit ist YouTube
nicht ganz alleine. Es gab und gibt
zahlreiche Websites, die euch
nicht reinlassen, wenn ihr ein Ad...
Hab ich das auch schon?
Ich hatte bis jetzt das Problem
noch nicht. Also auch
mit meinem Browser, wo ich
nicht eingeloggt bin.
Ach, die Musik ist an, ja.
Auch mit dem Browser, wo ich nicht eingeloggt bin.
Guck mal, wir haben heute total
viele YouTube-Videos geguckt.
Und es kam nichts?
Oder ist YouBlockOrigin einfach
5Head?
Das wird
bestimmt wieder nur
selektiv ausgerollt.
Ja, das stimmt.
Aber ich gebe bei Werbung
prinzipiell davon aus, dass es Bullshit ist.
Es gab sehr lange
die berühmte Komm-in-die-Gruppe-Werbung,
die euch natürlich abzocken will.
Im Endeffekt ist das
Scam und wird selbst
mit Meldung nicht immer
entfernt. Man kann es davon abgesehen,
jetzt musst du bei ApoRed auf den Channel
und kriegst für irgendwelche komischen Trading-Gruppen
in Dubai
ohne Werbung gekennzeichnet
zu sein.
Natürlich gab es auf Google
auch Werbung für die berühmte Fake-Chat-GPT-App,
die eure Log-in-Daten
gestohlen haben. Im Video
zum Malvertising haben wir darüber ausführlich
gesprochen. Werbung ist ein nicht zu verachtender
Angriffsvektor, wenn man sich
nicht gut darum kümmert, wer
werben darf. Vor allem, wenn wir daran denken,
wie viele Daten für
personalisierte Werbung gesammelt werden.
Aber klar ist eben auch, Werbung
für die Finanzierung von Inhalten
ist essentiell für viele.
Viele greifen also eigentlich
auch aus Sicherheitsgründen zu
einem Adblocker.
Aber das geht jetzt nicht mehr.
Zumindest nicht auf YouTube.
Und was Google angeht, da kümmern wir uns am Ende
drum. Denn YouTube ist sich
so sicher, dass es keine alternativen
Videoportale gibt, zu denen man
als User wechseln kann.
Also lasst uns kurz darüber sprechen,
was da eigentlich passiert. Auch aus
einer technischen Perspektive.
Erinnert ihr euch noch
dran, dass es vor
Jahren mal
diese Sache auf YouTube gab, dass
als Werbung
Videos geschaltet
wurden,
die halt auch
geschaltet wurden, die halt auch als
normale Videos veröffentlicht wurden.
Und da hatte ich wirklich mal, ich hatte mal
irgendwann, weil das gerade jemand
geschrieben hat, ich hatte mal irgendwann
als Werbung auch irgendwie so
45 Minuten Let's Play.
Hä? Das ist doch nicht
das Video, was du gerade angemacht hast.
Dann habe ich erst gecheckt, dass das Werbung ist.
Das ist aber schon
lange her. Da hatte ich
irgendwie so 45 Minuten Let's Play als
Werbung.
...Werbungsgame ändern. Und wir wissen
alle, Ads power the Internet.
Ich werde euch jetzt nicht sagen, dass
YouTuber nur mit YouTube Werbung
überleben können. Das stimmt schon lange nicht mehr.
Wir müssen uns eigentlich meist selbst
um Sponsoren kümmern. Das ist richtig.
Ganz ehrlich, Werbeeinnahmen
auf YouTube ist wahrscheinlich bei
allen, die das
semiprofessionell schon
machen und bei
den Profis, die das komplett
hauptberuflich professionell machen,
ganz was anderes,
reine YouTube AdSense Werbung
dürfte wahrscheinlich wirklich den kleinsten Teil
oder eines der kleinsten
Positionen, was Money-Einnahme
angeht, ausmachen.
...oder Millionen Aufrufe machen.
Deswegen vielen Dank an
GetInIT, dass sie auch dieses
Video, den Kanal und die Academy
damit unterstützen. GetInIT
veranstaltet am Donnerstag den 6.
Leute, ich hab so krass Hunger.
Dabei ist es erst 11.21 Uhr.
...26. Oktober
wieder die Job.io. Die Job.io
ist eine kostenlose Jobmesse mit
spannenden Talks, wie auch
meinem. Ich freue mich auch hier wieder
...um 14 Uhr zur Eröffnung
halten zu dürfen. Dieses Mal
geht es um IT-Consulting.
Einen Jobbereich, der für viele
glaube ich sehr spannend sein wird.
Unter anderem gelten wir IT-Sicherheitsberater
auch als
...
reaktivieren. Dann spricht man von Ad Reinsertion, also Werbung wieder einfügen.
Ich wusste bis jetzt nicht, dass es dafür ein extra Wort gibt.
Und dann kann natürlich die wieder eingefügte Werbung auch wieder entfernt werden und so
weiter und so fort. Naja. Aha, aber wie genau kann ich jetzt dieses Blockieren in einer
mobilen App durchführen? Naja, leider gar nicht. Deswegen gibt es auch keine direkten
Adblocker für die eigentlichen YouTube-Apps.
Bei Android hast du den Vorteil, da gibt es dann solche Dinger wie, wir nehmen die
offizielle YouTube-APK, dekompilieren die, bauen einen Adblocker ein und repackagen sie
neu und solche Dinge. Aber Pi-Haul bringt dir nichts an der Stelle. Also na doch, an
der Stelle bringt dir das vielleicht noch ein bisschen was, je nachdem von wo was ausgeliefert
wird, aber bei den neuesten Tricks bringt dir das nichts mehr.
Was es aber gibt, sind externe Tools, die den kompletten Netzwerkverkehr verändern.
Und hier geht es jetzt in das nächste Level. Ein Beispiel hier ist etwa das Pi-Haul. Läuft
auf einem Raspberry Pi und ist eine Art Netzwerk-Gateway. Ihr könnt euch das quasi wie einen zusätzlichen
Router vorstellen. Alles, was über das Internet geht, kommt erstmal durch den Pi-Haul.
Macht Pi-Haul mittlerweile mehr als DNS-Sachen einfach nicht auflösen? Ich habe es schon
lange nicht mehr benutzt. Durch und wird dort gewaschen. Manche Sachen werden also
zwar von der Website oder der App angefordert, kommen aber einfach nie an, weil sie im Pi-Haul
blockiert werden. Man kann beispielsweise im Pi-Haul einstellen, dass die Domain-Ads.com
einfach komplett verschluckt wird oder man lässt einfach einzelne Bilder nicht zu. Dann
werden die zwar versucht zu laden, kommen aber einfach nicht an und da die Webseite
oder App weiterhin funktionieren möchte, ignoriert sie das einfach. Ein anderer Ansatz
ist eine externe App. Sagen wir, ihr veröffentlicht die App YouTube Ad-Free. Diese App sieht dann
zum Beispiel exakt so aus wie YouTube und kann alles, was YouTube kann. Aber sie zeigt
nicht YouTube, sondern sie lädt die Videos von der YouTube-Programmierschnittstelle direkt
und zeigt die euch direkt an, ohne dass sie die Werbung dazu auch abfragt. Das lässt
sich aber YouTube normalerweise sehr, sehr gut bezahlen und die App müsste sich dann
irgendwie anders drum kümmern, anschaffen zu gehen. Ja, und sind wir mal ehrlich, wenn
eine Website etwas dagegen tun möchte, ist es wirklich kein Problem, Nutzer auszusperren.
Lasst uns mal kurz durch die Ad-Block-Möglichkeiten und deren Gegenmaßnahmen gehen.
Wird ein Skript. Unter iPhones wird es ja zunehmend schwieriger. Unter Android kannst
du glücklicherweise ordentlich sideloaden, was bei iOS so ohne weiteres, zumindest komfortabler
ist. Sideloadete Apps fliegen bei iOS ja runter, nach glaube ich fünf Tagen oder so.
Nicht geladen. Kann ich eine Warnung anzeigen oder den Nutzer einfach zum Verlassen der
Seite zwingen, indem ich das mit einem anderen Skript einfach überprüfe. Dasselbe gilt
natürlich, wenn der Container, der meine Werbung anzeigen sollte, plötzlich leer ist.
Das nennt sich Resource-Baiting. Wenn die Ressource nicht da ist, dann sperre ich den
Nutzer zum Beispiel aus. Das kann ich über JavaScript machen und sogar das veränderte
... Das machen aber viele Seiten nicht, weil es ihnen trotzdem wichtig ist, User zu haben.
SS kann ich mit JavaScript überprüfen. Und sie halt irrelevant werden, wenn alle Leute
abhauen. Deswegen denke ich, kalkulieren sogar sehr viele Seiten schon damit, dass die Werbung
nur auf den Bruchteil der Endgeräte überhaupt ankommt.
... JavaScript blockieren, dass das prüft, ob das Zeug blockiert wurde. Nun, das ist erweitertes
Adblock-Blocking. Und hier wird's jetzt spannend. Ihr seht schon, das hat sich über die letzten
paar Jahre immer mehr hochgeschaukelt und wurde immer extremer. Adblock-Blocker-Blocker
sind sogar seit einigen Jahren der Standard. Man blockiert ...
Adblock-Blocker-Blocker. Alter! ... blockiert also Skripte, die erkennen, ob wir Ads blockieren,
um die Ads blockieren zu können. Okay? YouTube hat ein gewaltiges Interesse daran,
dass ihr Inhalte schaut. Aber YouTube hat für längere Videos eine gewisse Marktmacht. Und
wenn ihr Inhalte schaut, geht es YouTube nicht unbedingt darum, dass ihr die Inhalte schaut,
sondern nur die Werbung. Denn die bringt Geld ein. Deswegen werden nicht ganz so werbefreundliche
Videos ... Da muss ich sagen, ich glaube, dass es YouTube nicht unbedingt nur darum geht,
dass man Werbung guckt, sondern eben auch die Plattform möchte auch die Zeit der Leute binden.
Natürlich, im Endeffekt, je mehr du guckst, je mehr Werbung guckst du, klar. Aber umso weniger
Zeit kannst du auf anderen Webseiten verbringen. Ich denke, das spielt da auch noch ein bisschen
mit rein. Aber sicherlich. Es ist ein bisschen wie in irgendeinem Kaufhaus, die dann ein Restaurant
haben und irgendwelche Ecken zum Abschillen und so. Die wissen auch, dass so Verweildauer im
Kaufhaus ganz wichtig ist dafür, weil umso länger du da bist, umso mehr kaufst du potenziell. Bei
YouTube guckst du halt Werbung. Hacking nur sehr spärlich auf eure Startseite befördert. Und ja,
das macht durchaus etwas aus. Denn über 70 Prozent von euch schauen über diese Startseite
YouTube. Hacking nur sehr spärlich auf eure Startseite befördert. Und ja,
YouTube. Ja klar, der Abo-Feed ist ja auch nicht mehr usable. Was manche Kanäle wie auch meinen,
ein wenig in seiner Freiheit einschränkt. Aber die eigentlichen Inhalte? Who cares? Also hat
YouTube eigentlich auch kein besonders großes Interesse an den Leuten, die keine Werbung sehen.
Denn die kosten YouTube Geld und bringen nichts ein. Und damit kann die neue Strategie Ausschluss
von denen, die einen Adblocker benutzen. Das war davor tatsächlich kein Thema. YouTube macht das
allerdings schwieriger als andere Webseiten. Die Website von YouTube ist komplex. Die wird
minimiert, optimiert, live verändert und vor allem werden Werbevideos nicht von einer fremden
Domain geladen, sondern sind selbst nur YouTube Videos. Ich kann zum Beispiel ganz einfach eines
meiner eigenen Videos zu einem Werbevideo machen. Dann seht ihr dieses Video, das eigentlich normales
YouTube Video ist, als Werbung vor anderen Videos. Das hat eine spannende Implikation.
Woher soll mein Adblocker wissen, dass jetzt das eine Video gesperrt werden soll, weil Werbung und
das andere nicht. An diesem Mechanismus scheitern auch schon einige Adblocker von Browsern übrigens.
Der einzige Adblocker, der zumindest manchmal funktioniert, ist aktuell uBlock Origin und
deshalb habe ich mir mal angesehen, was der eigentlich so genau macht. Im Grunde ist auch
deren Ansatz ziemlich fehleranfällig und führt häufig dazu, dass etwas gar nicht funktioniert.
Ihr könnt viele andere Addons nicht mehr nutzen und auch nicht stacken und müsst immer mal wieder
auch selbst aktiv werden. Sie blockieren aber im Grunde nicht stacken und
die Leute immer, wie die da irgendwelche, über die User könnte ich mich immer aufregen.
Ach Moment, das geht um Adblock Plus. Ja gut, Adblock Plus ist auch wirklich fragwürdig.
Auch selbst aktiv werden. Sie blockieren aber im Grunde auch nur einige Netzwerk-Requests,
wie das auch der Piehole macht. Sie blockieren einige Elemente auf der Webseite und einige
Skripte, die geladen werden. Das wird allerdings zunehmend schwieriger und es gibt einen
Punkt, ab dem niemand mehr etwas tun kann. YouTube ändert derzeit seine Skripte für
Werbung und die Orte, wo die Werbung liegt, zweimal am Tag, schreiben sie zumindest.
Krass.
Die werden dann dynamisch geladen und das passiert wahrscheinlich voll automatisch
auf YouTube Seite. Jedes Mal, wenn das passiert, muss allerdings beim Adblocker
ein neuer Eintrag hinterlegt werden, der sagt, das ist Werbung und das dann blockiert. YouTube
muss also eigentlich dafür nicht wirklich was tun und damit haben wir eine Asymmetrie im Aufwand.
YouTube kann hier vermutlich einfach sagen, das ist ein Video, das ist eine Werbung und das beim
selben Skript, das im Hintergrund läuft. Das kann jederzeit einfach geändert werden und so können
sich die einzelnen Skripte auch mal überlagern und man blockiert aus Versehen ein Video statt
einer Werbung.
Ja, neue Adblock-Versionen kriegst du im Leben nicht so schnell. Die musst du ja
im App Store reviewen lassen. Das heißt, du müsstest den Adblocker dynamisch die
neuesten Sachen runterladen lassen von irgendeinem Service.
Sieht man gar keine Werbung, kann es sein, dass man sogar ausgelockt wird,
manchmal zumindest. Und YouTube kann natürlich auch die Frequenz massiv erhöhen.
Zweimal am Tag kann der Anfang sein. Wir können aber auch bei zweimal pro Minute liegen und dann
wird es für die Leute, die die Filterlisten bei Adblockern pflegen, ein unfassbarer
Mehraufwand, das alles zu betreiben. Bedenkt man dann noch, dass die Videos auf der Webseite nur
dann laden, nachdem eine Werbung gesehen wurde, dann kann das ein sehr schnelles Aus für viele
Adblocker bedeuten.
Dahinter steckt natürlich die Idee, YouTube Premium zu etablieren und ja,
ich hab das selbst schon seit einigen Jahren. Da ich kein Spotify hab und nur YouTube Music,
ist mir das allemal wert. Es hört sich zwar nach einem fairen Modell an, das sowohl uns
Creator als auch eure Zeit bedenkt, aber ich persönlich finde es ziemlich schade,
wenn Menschen, die sich kein Premium leisten wollen oder können, zugeballert werden mit Werbung.
Zumal das am Ende echt viele Seiten wären, für die man ein Premium bräuchte. Und ich erschrecke
jedes Mal, wenn ich woanders YouTube schaue, wie unfassbar viel Werbung eigentlich kommt.
Auf der anderen Seite, vielleicht wird ja dann die Frequenz und Menge an Werbung wieder etwas
reduziert, wenn eigentlich mehr Leute im Durchschnitt Werbung sehen.
Das glaube ich nicht.
Aber es gibt ein Thema, das wir noch nicht betrachtet haben. Das sind Google Ads. Wenn
YouTube mit diesem Modell Erfolg hat, dann liegt natürlich nahe, dass man das auf Google Ads
ausweitet. So ein Update eben. Sozusagen eine Werbung, die sie nicht ablehnen.
Also wenn es wirklich advanced wird und irgendwann mal sogar die Werbung encoded
wird in den Videostream, was schwierig ist, wie gesagt, das erzeugt auch unglaublichen
Rechenaufwand auf Anbieterseite. Dann sind sogar in gedownloadeten Videos Werbung drin.
Und das auf jeder Webseite. Das fände ich ziemlich furchtbar. Denn mit all den
Pushbenachrichtigungen erlauben, Newsletter, Registrierungsangeboten und Ads, die einfach
mitten ins Gesicht reinpoppen, sind die meisten Blogs und Nachrichtenwebsites einfach nicht mehr
benutzbar. Und im Gegensatz zu YouTube Premium gibt es kein solches Programm für Google Ads.
Aber es ist auch deutlich schwieriger, das Ganze mit Google Ads durchzuführen.
Denn irgendwo auf der Webseite müssen die Ads ja angezeigt werden. Bei YouTube ist der
Verteiler der Ads derselbe wie der Anbieter der Videos. Dadurch ist dieses Mischverhältnis einfach
sehr viel leichter. Eine Nachrichtenwebseite muss irgendwo auf der Webseite einen gewissen Bereich
reservieren und sie müssen die Werbung von extern, also von einem anderen Anbieter,
als ihren restlichen Inhalt nachladen. Dieser für Werbung reservierte Bereich,
der kann ja relativ easy blockiert werden. Und die externe Domain, wo die Werbung herkommt,
die kann auch blockiert werden. Allerdings, wenn der Bereich blockiert ist, könnte euch die Website
rauswerfen. Gut, bleibt Domain blockieren, sprich nicht einfach von Google Ads irgendwas laden.
Und hier wird es jetzt nochmal ein wenig lustig. Denn Google Ads ist ausschließlich im Frontend
eurer Webseite aktiv. Heißt, wenn ich auf meiner Webseite Werbung von Google integriere,
dann macht mein Server, wo also die Webseite liegt, nichts mit der Werbung selbst. Die kommt
nicht von meinem Server. Erkennt die tatsächliche Werbung, die ihr dann seht nicht mal. Man bindet
einfach nur ein Skript ein und das Skript lädt dann die Werbung direkt von eurem Browser aus.
Deswegen ist das so leicht zu blockieren. Auch macht man nun, was man bei YouTube tut,
sprich man wechselt ständig das Skript, dann müsste man das Ganze serverseitig machen. Ich
als Entwickler der Webseite habe also plötzlich mehrere Skripte bzw. sogar einen Algorithmus,
die euch die Werbung dann anzeigen. Das heißt, ich liefere euch im besten Fall die Werbung und
nicht mehr Google direkt. Die Werbung wird von Google an meinen Server geladen und mein Server
zeigt euch dann direkt die Werbung an, nicht mehr Google. Dadurch wird das Blockieren zwar schwerer,
aber das heißt auch, dass nicht mehr Google eure Daten sammelt und sagt, zu welchem Thema ihr jetzt
Werbung bekommt, sondern ich müsste das direkt tun. Und das fände ich ehrlich gesagt ziemlich gut,
denn aktuell sammeln Werbetreibende überall Daten, massig und massiv. Ich bin zum Beispiel auf EMP,
kriege auf einer völlig anderen Webseite dann aber die Werbung für EMP. Ich sehe mir irgendein
Kleidungsstück an und ich kriege überall Werbung für ähnliche Kleidung. Das geht aber nur,
weil Google entscheidet, welche Werbung wir sehen, nicht der Websitebetreiber. Denn Google
hat durch Tracking die Informationen, was ihr überall euch ansehen wollt und angesehen habt.
Wechseln wir zu dieser etwas schwereren, zu blockierenden Art von Werbung, dann entscheidet
der Betreiber der Website. Und der hat wahrscheinlich nicht die Informationen,
welche Techwearhose ich mir vorgestern angesehen habe. Und das heißt, Werbung wechselt von
personalisiert, vielleicht wenn wir Glück haben, zu kontextbasiert. Wenn ich einen Artikel zu Techwear
Fashion lese, kriege ich Techwear Werbung. Wenn ich einen Artikel zu AI lese, kriege ich AI Werbung.
Ich glaube sogar, ehrlich gesagt, dass das kontext, äh nicht kontext, das personalisierte Werbung,
ich glaube sogar, die meisten 0815 User finden das gut.
Eine AI App. Und das wiederum würde heißen, vielleicht zumindest, Google sammelt...
Da kriege ich ja endlich das empfohlen, was mich auch interessiert. Ja, das ist ja gerade der Sinn
davon. Gekauft hättest du dir das sonst nicht, aber... Vielleicht weniger Daten über mich. Und ehrlich
gesagt, würde mich das ziemlich glücklich machen. Ja, vielleicht sieht man dann mehr Werbung, aber
vielleicht drehen dann alle auch wieder eine Stufe runter, wenn die Einnahmen insgesamt gestiegen sind.
Das glaube ich nicht. Weil eben nicht mehr so viele Apps kopiert werden. Weniger dafür
kontextbezogene Werbung, damit könnte ich ehrlich gesagt sogar leben. Und im Zweifel gibt es ja für
Seiten, die man viel nutzt, immer noch Premium. An der Stelle vielleicht eine kurze Frage in die
Runde. Ich habe überlegt, für unsere Bootstrap Academy als Option zu geben, Videos ohne YouTube
zu schauen. Also aktuell sind die meisten ja von YouTube eingebettet und ich würde sie eigentlich
ganz gerne nativ integrieren. Ich habe ja die Videodateien. Oh, Chet, ich glaube, wir sollten
denen das Wupplers Videoarchiv verkaufen. Auch z.B. bei den Hacking-Videos schon der Fall ist. Das
ginge allerdings. Inklusive AI-Transcribing. Weil Serverkosten. Der Speicherplatz würde ja drastisch
steigen, wenn ich das für jedes Video mache. Wäre das für euch eine Option oder würdet ihr dann
tatsächlich lieber die YouTube-Videos schauen wollen? Schreibt mir das ganz gerne mal. Danke
und bis Donnerstag. See you. Ja, gutes Video. Sehr, sehr nice. Leute, ich habe übertrieben
Hunger. Ich geh jetzt was essen. Was macht ein Fachinformatiker für System? Alter, der ist ja mal
super, super Business. Keck Business, Alter. Der nicht. Der sieht auch nicht so Keck Business aus.
Auf dem Thumbnail sieht er mega Keck Business aus. Mit dem Anzug. Hier Leute, jetzt wird's Zeit.
PPoFatTime. Ja, Nudeln mit Lachs, korrekt. Okay, Leute, wir sehen uns im nächsten Stream. Macht's gut,
bis dann. C, U.